Sir Richard,
what did you have for breakfast?
I had a yogurt with pistachios,
some coffee and water.
That was once it got to the airport and I've had some almonds.
Good man.
More water,
more water,
flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Soda is brought to you by me undies.
If I'm not going commando,
I'm in me.
Andy's,
I have been testing these underwear for three to four months now,
pretty much every day and in fact throughout bunch of my other underwear this
morning and on the road in the house,
they are extremely comfortable.
They look good,
feel good.
They are made of micro model two times softer than cotton as scientifically
tested using the call.
Bought to method sounds very fancy.
Of course.
And I get a lot of compliments from ladies for these.
You don't get diaper butt,
you don't get the tired elastic band.
They look great and they have underwear for both men and women.
Check out [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim and you can see everything I've
been wearing.
They're ridiculous.
The sublime,
everything in between and colluding.
My favorite,
which is called out.
And I would be remiss if I didn't mention their lounge pants.
This is a new thing and I have been wearing their lounge pants when I record
podcast.
I've been wearing them out and about when I'm walking the dog meeting people for
coffee.
And they are extremely comfortable though.
They're made from the same material as the underwear,
but some of them,
like the blue ones,
I have have pockets so you can walk about without seeming like you're off of
your meds and completely crazy.
So that is awesome.
And if you're not happy with the first pair you try on,
I assume that it refers to the underwear,
they'll refund you completely and you can keep the pair you tried on for free.
But if you're that kind of person,
you should be ashamed because that's disgusting.
Uh,
me on [inaudible] dot com slash Tim check it out.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my God,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important.
It will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me,
it just covers the basis,
takes a load off my puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim.
Hello ducks,
hoons and melanoma looked that one up.
Belgian malinois.
If you want to see a flash of a creature,
go across your screen and take out a criminal.
Just look for Canine Belgian malinois on Youtube.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
And every episode,
as you may know,
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers to try to seize out.
She's out.
I'm not sure if that was English,
the habits,
the morning routines,
the influences,
the favorite books,
etc. That have made them so exceptionally good at what they do.
And that ranges from the Arnold Swartz,
niggers of the world,
literally to Jon Favreau to stand up,
comedians,
athletes,
musicians,
chess prodigies,
everyone in between.
And today we have a tattoo to heretic Richard Bets.
He's known for wine and whiskey.
Why is that?
Well,
Richard Bets served as the wine director at the little Nell,
very,
very famous spot and Aspen from 2000 to 2008 but that's not so interesting
compared to the next point,
which is Richard passed the court of Master [inaudible] master exams.
So becoming a master lea on his very first attempt,
and that's meant he was only the ninth person in history to do so.
And I first met Richard through the investing mastermind.
Vonda Kinte himself,
Chris Sacca who will no doubt be the most successful venture capitalist of all
time if things keep going as we see them moving.
And I also had him on the podcast and Richard and I hit it off immediately.
He can help train your senses for anything including wine whiskey,
his current obsession of mezcal and far beyond that.
He's also done a ton of experimentation,
gotten a lot of tattoos,
almost been shot in Mexico and uh,
developed along the way and incredibly,
incredibly uncanny lot of adverbs in this intro to simplify the complex.
So we get along.
He's very good at deconstructing and simplifying himself.
And in this conversation we talk about nearly everything imaginable,
ranging from the value of quitting a,
I didn't expect this to be such a big part of his story,
but from that to tricks of the trade,
meaning related to tasting wine,
the test itself,
travel tips because he travels something like 300 plus days a year and starter
wines,
all sorts of things.
We also,
as we are doing the interview,
drink a boatload of whiskey.
I taste,
he teaches and I have pictures on the blog post or in the blog posts that show
you what Richard looks like,
what we drank,
et cetera.
So that that may be a good visual reference for you.
So just go a four hour work,
week.com,
forward slash podcast all spelled out,
or it's got a four hour work week.com and click on podcast and you will find
Richard,
uh,
the,
the whiskeys were amazing.
And a side note,
by the way,
maybe you didn't know this,
that it's whiskey,
w,
h,
I s K,
e y when it's from countries that have an e in their names such as America,
but it's whiskey,
y without any,
when the country names don't have any.
That is the,
where the origin is of the given whiskey.
So Scotland,
Japan,
that's whiskey without me.
Richard taught me that among many,
many other things.
So last but not least,
I must say it because I love it and I've already given it out as a gift.
A,
Richard is the author of brand new book,
the essential scratch and sniff guide to becoming a whiskey.
No,
it all,
which is sitting right in front of me with whiskey stands all over it.
It distills,
see what I did there.
A couple of lifetimes worth of study down to 24 pages.
It's super short and I shook it out at the very least it gives you a bunch of
rules of thumb,
like the whiskey whiskey trick with the e versus knowing so that you can impress
your friends and not look like a dumb ass at the bar,
which is pretty awesome because less dumb ass and more smart ass always good.
So with that said,
and without further ado,
some of you have given me shit online for saying without further ado,
and then talking for another two minutes like I'm doing right now.
So without further ado,
please enjoy my conversation with Richard Bets.
Richard,
welcome to the show.
Thanks to him.
Good to be here.
Yeah man,
it's been a little while since we hung out.
Has Been,
and uh,
let's start at the beginning.
For those people who don't know you,
why wine,
how did you get into wine?
And
I got into wine,
um,
because of my seventh grade German teacher,
Mrs Mrs Pritchard,
and she was,
she's a total bitch.
Um,
and I didn't learn anything about German in seventh grade,
but I did learn.
Um,
and sometimes I'm slow to digest the lesson,
but I definitely learned that you gotta do what you love.
So I walked in,
I walked into class that day and um,
first is cool.
I was like,
this lady is intense and I don't like this subject.
And I didn't go and it didn't matter.
And at that,
I did know at that time that it just didn't matter.
Like if I don't go to the class,
the other class I never went to with typing,
just not doing it,
just not doing it.
Um,
I don't have the student council hall passes,
Let,
let you screw off like that,
you know,
20 some years ago.
But,
um,
it was,
it felt great at the time.
Felt bad at the time,
but,
and I didn't understand the larger lesson and I'll put it,
came back to me over over time where I went to school and we talks at home and
did my undergraduate work there and just struggled,
you know,
is what did you study Undergrad?
I tried a lot of things.
Uh,
I went with the idea of doing marine biology specifically and the whole biology
department was populated by young kids that didn't really have an interest in
biology.
They had an interest in going to med school and when you grade on the curve,
that means that intense things happen.
Like your slides are broken and it's very cutthroat,
backstabbing.
I was like,
this is just anathema to everything that I believe in and how I want to live.
Um,
so bailed on that and then had this wild hair that I should study econ.
And that was just foolish.
That was all so boring.
And so they went to poly psy and ended up with a minor in Poli Sci.
But,
and that was interesting and that's kind of how the world turns and was as cool.
But I need to be outdoors.
And that was,
that's really my compass is being outdoors.
I don't think I wore shoes until I was five.
Um,
and,
and so I found my way to the geology school,
you know,
and it's definitely not rocks for jocks there.
Um,
that's a,
that's a funny thing that should be dispelled at some point.
Um,
but it's actually jocks meeting and easy way for the jocks to pass trek.
Totally.
So the lesson then from the German class was you could opt out of things that
you disliked.
He exactly.
Totally.
You know what,
I'm just not doing that.
And so,
um,
geology was great.
Got me outside again,
got me out of Los Angeles,
which was awesome.
I mean,
I love La.
I love being there.
Then I like being there now,
but you know,
I need to spend time outdoors.
And if you're in the middle of Los Angeles as a student,
it's kind of,
you know,
it's hard to do.
Um,
so geology was the thing.
And then,
um,
I took a break from it blow off my senior year.
I lived in Italy.
Um,
all my friends thought I was a nut.
It is great.
And then after my own heart and I was on the five year plan,
awesome.
That was great.
Um,
came back,
finished and um,
I really wanted to do environmental law.
That was really a thing.
So I thought,
well,
if I'm not a marine biologist,
I want to work to conserve this stuff.
You know,
how do we do this?
Well,
I thought,
well,
I think one approach could be to speak the language of the scientific community.
Take that the law school,
then speak the language of the legal community and do your job well.
So I went and did a graduate thesis in Paleo Fluvial Morphology.
So ancient river system makeup.
Is that what that translates to?
What was this like?
I'm worth fluvial fluvial that's the river part.
And it wasn't,
it wasn't so much about that topic at hand.
It was about digging deep in the scientific method and what it means to be an
investigator at that level.
Um,
and that was great.
I did find,
um,
through that time that the farther you go with it,
the smaller the scale.
At which you investigate.
So,
you know,
I spend a lot of time in a small dark hot room with a scanning electron
microscope.
And this is what I'm in,
you know,
during the summers I'm living in Flagstaff,
Arizona,
which is beautiful.
I mean,
right next to the Grand Canyon.
It's amazing.
I didn't see any of it,
you know,
cause you're in the lab.
So that was that,
that was happening simultaneously.
Um,
I was clerking at a small firm there.
I clerked for,
for my senator and on Capitol Hill,
Dennis Deconcini from Arizona.
Um,
I clerked at Skadden,
arps and the world's largest law firm because big,
uh,
big Kahuna.
Totally.
Um,
that was when I was in la.
And then when I was in Grad School in Flagstaff,
I was clerking for a small environmental firm.
And I found it didn't matter whether you were doing environmental or you're
doing bankruptcy,
it was the same board,
like the monopoly board making the same motions,
you know,
past park place.
Every time you just traded the hat for the shoe or whatever your piece was,
you know,
it's still the same game.
Right.
And I found I didn't like the game.
And so I was really ripe for this moment.
And this is what brought back Mrs Pritchard and seventh grade is that at the end
of a,
of a very long day with that scan electron microscope,
um,
it was,
I was bout to be thesis defense weekends,
a couple of days in advance of this moment.
Um,
I walked out and I was,
I was just not feeling it.
Um,
thesis was great.
I was ready to defend it.
Uh,
and I was supposed to go to law school six weeks later.
So,
uh,
I walked out of the lab,
I hopped over the fence and ran across,
what is route 66,
they're in Flagstaff to a small restaurant slash wine store.
And I walked in and I didn't know anything about wine.
I just know that I drank it on the daily and in Italy and how much that meant to
me.
And I walked in and I bought totally based on site and I was like,
I kind of recognize that label and I pull off the shelf and I took it home and I
popped the cork and I poured a glass.
And that first smell,
that first smell took me back to a moment that I had lived almost four years
earlier when living in Italy.
And I remembered a dinner I had had specifically at the Australia Ching Galley
Bianco,
which is on board vote,
was on Jaco and Florence.
And I remember where I sat and where my compaigns sat and what she ate and what
she wore and what I eat and what the waitress did right and wrong that night.
And all that just came rushing back from one smell.
And the next day I was describing this experience to a friend,
um,
really good friend,
best friend in life,
actually,
uh,
Bobby Stuckey and who was getting into food,
wine himself.
And I said,
you know,
Bobby,
I don't want to go to law school and I don't want to do the science anymore
longer.
I want to do food wine.
And he's like,
well you should.
I was like,
well then I will.
And so I walked back to the firm.
I was supposed to be an illegal library at that point on someone's billable
hour,
which wasn't happening.
Um,
so walk with a permanent and I quit.
I did defend my thesis cause then it was that week.
Um,
but I call it law school and said,
look,
I'm not coming and hopped off the cliff and got into food and wine.
And that was,
that was a big moment.
You know,
your parents,
everyone has expectations for you.
He's like,
you know what,
I'm just not doing,
it just doesn't feel good.
Did
what else in your family have that,
that confidence or compunction?
My dog is,
is Klein the bottom of her crate just for,
for notice her and will reason for enjoyment really.
Was there anyone else in your family who
had that ability to show,
to switch gears and to quit?
Not In such a negative connotation,
but in the w in the sense of changing directions.
Did you,
did you get that from anywhere else?
You know,
I,
I
has to have come from my parents,
I think,
but they,
they switched gears
in to me a much more impressive way and they both came from very,
very tough places.
Um,
you know,
complete poverty,
very rough,
particularly in my father's case,
very nomadic in my mother's case and her large family.
Where did they grow up?
Um,
my mom all over the eastern seaboard,
but really settled in Syracuse in my father in Syracuse.
Um,
and his dad was a really rough dude.
Yeah.
You know,
it's treat brawls,
nickels,
his fist and drugs,
alcohol,
all kinds of intense stuff.
Um,
and so they,
I mean,
they're the people I'm most proud of to,
to come from such intense circumstances like that be the first of your families
ever to go to college and then make your way out west and actually make your
way.
I mean,
that's,
they definitely change relative to what came before them.
So heroes in a different way.
What did your,
what did your parents do when you were growing up?
So my mom,
um,
educator and she ran for a long time,
something called the teenage parent program,
which gave kids an opportunity.
If you were pregnant,
you could stay in school.
Um,
they had a daycare facility in the school and this is everything from sixth
graders through high school.
Um,
so when you can bring your kids as cool but two,
you actually are in school and you graduate in three,
learn how to take care of your kid at the same time.
So she really,
she kept so many kids in school,
which is huge.
Just huge.
Yeah.
Um,
she eventually made her way to the University of Arizona.
and she did her phd and then ended up as a researcher there at the U of a and my
dad,
a biomedical engineer at the University Hospital there has his whole life.
So I can see now we're,
I'm skipping ahead in my own mind,
but I can see how the sort of biomedical engineer scientist aspect and the
educator aspect tie pretty neatly into a lot of what you do now.
Totally.
But I'm skipping ahead.
I don't want to,
I don't want to give away too much of the middle of the movie,
so we'll go back to the beginning.
So you decide law.
Thanks.
But no thanks.
Yup.
Food and beverage then what and how old were you at the time?
So just finishing Grad School in 96.
I'm 25.
And um,
you know,
I always think that I'm somewhat late to the party.
You know,
like people decide I'm into food wine when they're like 18,
17,
16.
And you see it as very young people into it today and that's great.
I'm always slow to make my decision.
Um,
but when it's made it happens.
And so we moved.
Um,
I just gotten married to my first wife,
uh,
at the time we moved to Missoula,
Montana,
not known as a bastion of great food or wine.
No offense.
If there are any Montanans out,
there's all,
I've eaten very well.
They're very frequently.
But,
um,
if you want to go learn about this stuff is probably not the best place to do
it.
But,
uh,
my first wife had gotten a tenure track job at the University of Montana job
tenure track or tenure track job at the University of Montana,
not unlike the legal profession.
And so wisely.
Yup.
Sign up and here it is.
Here's your life before you.
Um,
that's an intense thought.
So we moved there and I worked in all kinds of places,
but the,
the first place I worked and cooked was I walked into the Red Lion Motor Inn,
which in 1996 was for sure the nicest restaurant in town,
you know,
and,
and it was a motor and you park your car in front of your room,
that kind of place.
Um,
so I walked in and there is a master chef,
which is a real designation.
Um,
I think it means,
it means you can do all kinds of things including put on a brunch for like 3000
people and carve the hell out of a block of ice and turned into a swan or
something.
But,
um,
that,
that's a real thing.
And I walked in and his name was,
was Hans and Hans said,
Oh,
you want to learn to cook?
Huh,
okay,
yeah,
sure.
Here,
hold this.
And he puts an egg pan in my hand,
a little Saute Pan,
I'm holding it.
And he slaps a piece of toast in it and he says,
flip it.
And I flip it.
He says,
great,
you're the breakfast cook for the whole hotel,
whole hotel.
And so we're really working on our super hippy mantra at that time.
Um,
which meant no car,
nothing automated riding bikes,
which is great in the summer,
you know,
and that,
that's the,
that's the big like bait and switch with Montana is that summer's Eden and
winter is the opposite.
Um,
so October came and the sun went away and uh,
you know,
then you're on your bike at 4:00 AM and the snow and the bitter cold peddling.
And to open up this huge hotel and cook breakfast for everybody.
And it was thrilling.
It was be,
remains one of my favorite jobs ever.
Um,
you know,
it's a funny point in life when you don't,
you don't really have the same stake in things as you do later in life.
Um,
so it was great.
Like,
yeah,
I'm going to open this thing up and you've a flat top,
you know,
like that flat griddle you cook on that's 20 feet long.
Wow.
Rocking eight waffle irons and you're cooking oven,
you know,
by the sheet pan in the back.
And you know,
while you're doing that,
you're steering though it's,
and getting the whole thing ready,
just open up.
Then you open that huge line by yourself and the order start flooding in.
And I think I'm a big believer that in the restaurant business you either have
the synapse or you don't,
it doesn't mean you're a good person or bad person,
but it does mean you either shouldn't be in the business or you shouldn't be in
the business.
And you mean like back of the house,
like boom,
boom,
multitasking.
Exactly.
Order sequencing and all of that timing,
etc. Yeah,
it's a,
it's a real thing.
It's tough.
Yeah.
Um,
and some people find it thrilling and do it really well and some people find it
thrilling and don't do it really well.
And some people don't find it either,
you know?
Um,
but if,
if you've have that in an imagine,
some of you that are listening do you,
it's thrilling and I loved it.
What,
what is a way that someone who hasn't worked in that type of circumstance?
I've worked in restaurants,
I worked in restaurants for many summers,
but I was never,
I was never on the line are cooking in the back or anything like that.
And I was always from the house as a bus boy or whatnot,
getting abused by patrons.
But the,
uh,
you can get that to you in the back of the house.
But what if someone wanted to try to predict if they would be good and that type
of environment,
what are characteristics or experiences or traits?
Like if you had to pick some of you do recruit for the back of the house,
but you couldn't test them in the back of the house?
I would,
I would look for someone who,
um,
for sure can handle stress,
uh,
because everyone around you has the possibility to just totally lose it.
And if they start freaking out,
are you going to freak out with them?
And then the whole ship thing.
So,
so stress management's huge.
Um,
this seems silly,
but you gotta be able to deal with the heat,
like the physical heat.
Later,
a few years later I had a,
or a year later I had a different cooking job and standing in front of,
I was Greer Danesh means he worked the grill and standing between the grill on
the line and have the little pocket thermometer in my,
my chef's coat pocket and he'd read 130 degrees all night long.
It was a real thing.
It's really,
really warm and some of these places,
so you've got to do with eat,
you have to deal with the stress,
the pressure and keep cool.
And you have to be able to multitask,
you know?
I mean if you,
if you get,
if you were like a,
a myopic thinker,
it's not for you.
But if you can say,
I'm doing this,
I'm doing this.
And meanwhile you have all these little timers going off in your head,
you know,
it probably means you don't sleep well all the time.
Um,
I'm that guy woke up three times last night just thinking about stuff.
Right.
And it doesn't bother me,
you know,
it just is.
Um,
so those,
those would be the three things.
So you're in Montana biking through October,
snow to open up the line.
What,
what did you like about that?
I mean,
what,
what excited you about that?
The pace for sure.
Um,
you know,
it was really important to me,
Tim,
is that,
um,
it was on the job learning.
And so before,
before I actually got that first job,
we got to Montana,
I was like,
okay,
well I guess I'm going to figure this out or am I going to take time off and
then go to culinary school?
And I was like,
you know what,
I've done a lot of school,
right?
And I'm kind of done with that.
A lot of prep,
a ton of prep,
let's do something.
And so I went and talked to a chef and I said,
hey man,
this is what I'm thinking about.
Like I'm either going to like ask you for a job or,
um,
this was after I was already working at the red line in,
uh,
I mean,
they're gonna ask you for a job or I'm thinking about culinary school.
And he's like,
well,
here's the deal.
You can come here today and you can ask me for a job.
And I'll say,
yeah,
great.
Here are the potatoes and get peeling.
Or you can go to culinary school,
spend two more years of your life preparing,
spending,
you know,
30,
40 grand a year in bills to be there.
Then you can come to me and asked me for a job and I'll say,
yeah,
sure.
Here's,
here's a,
you know,
big pot of potatoes.
Get peeling.
Same thing up to you.
Yeah.
Same,
same.
Like,
okay,
I,
I'm,
I'm pretty good at math.
I got this,
we're the potatoes.
Let's do it.
That simple.
Yeah,
no,
that makes perfect sense.
And when,
when then did the,
the,
the nectar of the gods,
when did the wine entered the picture?
Yeah,
so I was,
um,
while in the kitchen I was always reading about wine.
I knew that I wanted to do both cook and work as a similar Yay.
Um,
I thought working in the back of the house made the most sense to start.
I do like that self reliance of really learning how to feed yourself and feed
others and you know,
make your table warm and interesting.
That matters to me.
Um,
so I started there but all the while read,
read,
taste,
taste.
And um,
I had an early mentor who said,
beg,
borrow,
steal,
but taste,
taste,
taste.
And that's,
that's the everything.
If you don't have a context and we'll talk more about that later,
but if you don't have a context,
you don't,
you don't have any framework within which to hold anything together.
Even accumulate knowledge.
You've got to have a context.
Context,
meaning,
uh,
like the,
like having the letters of the alphabet to spell words,
having just like the descriptors that you can only acquire through developing a
database of exactly that.
Different flavors actually that,
yeah,
I mean it was actually no different than geology.
You only know what sandstone is because it relates to mudstone and it's more
coarse grain.
And you know that mudstone is only mudstone because it's more coarse grained
than siltstone.
Yeah.
So on and so forth.
It was not to geek out on,
but yeah,
it's just how things relate to each other.
Um,
so I was taste,
taste tasting.
We left Montana about 11 months later,
almost to the day.
Um,
cause we,
we moved there,
we bought a house and old house remodeled it.
The Sun went away as I said.
And uh,
I'm a solar powered kid growing up in the southwest.
Um,
so that house was sold before the sun came out in May and we moved to Tucson
where I worked for the second chef.
I cooked for him,
really loved Alan Zeeman,
who's,
if you didn't use a rubber spatula to get the gloss,
you know,
the intense beef protein that you worked on two days to reduce down from beef
bones.
If he didn't use a rubber spatula to get that out of the Pan,
he would dock your pay check and make you make soap.
It was a real learning experience.
You made everything.
Nothing came in a box.
Um,
so while I worked for him,
that's where I had this Greer damn position where you're on the grill and it was
130 degrees all night.
It was also that where the waiters had to walk by and they knew that I was
really into wine.
So then they start asking questions like,
oh,
I know Richie,
you know,
the wine list.
And like,
what should I pair with this?
What should I pay with that?
So I became the sort of defacto volunteer similarly from the kitchen.
And had you been,
had you been acquiring,
uh,
tastes at that point?
Yup.
I spending,
I mean,
still had basically no money.
You're earning minimum wage.
Um,
and I spent every dime I could on every bottle of wine I could find.
Yeah.
And so you bought,
how did you choose bottles to taste?
Things I hadn't had before and in areas I wanted to explore.
So,
um,
you know,
I don't drink much Chilean wine today,
but at that point I was like,
okay,
this people are talking about this.
So what is this about?
So then it was a deep dive into to Chile,
like how do these,
what are these things about how they relate to each other?
He's this one just an outlier or does it,
how does it fit in the context of the whole,
really very methodical about that.
So you thought you then categorize mostly geographically yes.
In the beginning.
Yep.
Yeah.
Well that makes sense.
I mean,
it gives you,
it gives you at least a plan for starting,
right?
Totally.
Much as you can,
like compartmentalize in an orderly way so you're not just helter skelter trying
capriciously this wine after the next.
Exactly.
And ultimately wine,
the intellectual value of wine comes from this idea of terroir and terroir.
It's a French word for this,
this notion that everything that makes up the wine makes up the place that goes
into the wine is this idea of terroir.
So you should pick up a glass and it should reflect,
reflect a place just like that ordinary bottle of soil,
the climate,
the end,
the barometric farm down the road and everything.
Everything goes in there.
And so I mean that's what got me into it in the first place.
You know,
because I picked up that bottle of wine,
I didn't know anything about it,
but that sensory memory got me to blow off law school.
Right?
So,
so I kept on that path like,
okay,
well what is it about this place that makes,
you know,
that's a common thread amongst these wines.
Be at Merlo or Cabernet or whatever it may be.
And,
and when you can take that trip and a glass of wine that that's the intellectual
value,
that's the part that matters.
And how I convince myself I'm getting smarter when I'm drinking.
And so your,
so your waitstaff start asking you questions and you're on the line.
I'm on the line cooking,
like do this,
do that.
And you know,
it was like a free swing because I didn't have to face the guests,
I didn't have any consequences and totally practice without God's got to see
what,
what might a question be that w like a waiter would ask what,
what goes with this entree?
Yeah.
Or Hey,
you know,
your special tonight.
Like how,
where's the acid at?
Like is it going to work with the Soviet block or is it lower acid and I should
use chardonnay?
Or Hey,
I saw you put Sarell with grapes and you know,
how is that going to work with this,
you know,
those sorts of things.
Cool.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Yeah,
it's super cool.
And then what them then,
um,
this was in Tucson and you're like,
well,
why would you go from Montana to Tucson,
another place?
It's not necessarily known as a,
as a culinarily hot,
uh,
important hotbed.
Um,
I went to Tucson after going to Portland and San Francisco both,
and this is in 97,
97 98.
And,
um,
I believe in myself and really believe that,
you know,
in,
in my ability to make a decision to do something I love and then when I'm doing
it,
then I'm going to put everything I have into it.
And in my,
the best at it,
I have no idea,
but I know I'll try harder than most.
Um,
so I went to Portland and it's like,
man,
there's so many kids getting into the food scene that I'm just going to have to
get in line with these kids.
And I went to San Francisco,
same story,
like just super expensive to be here,
um,
although less,
less than now.
Um,
but also just huge lines of kids competing for positions.
And then there were two,
these two chefs that,
um,
I wanted to work for in Tucson.
They were actually great,
well regarded on national level and nobody wanted to move there to work with
them.
So it was like,
I can get immediate access,
supercharged my learning and my path.
And I did.
So I went to that second chef and I said,
hey man,
I want to Yano someone to work,
work with you.
This is why I'm in Arizona.
And he said,
great,
what have you been doing?
I told him how about my work with the alzine and the other chef.
And he's like,
okay,
cool.
Well why don't you audition?
And so you spend a week auditioning in the kitchen and doing all this different
stuff.
The end of the week we sit down in his office and he was like,
okay,
so I understand you've also been spending time learning about wine.
It was like,
yeah,
doing this and pass my first quarter master.
So many A's exam and your first one court of Master sommeliers of masters of
Court of exactly.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's a big mouthful like that.
Um,
which is a certifying body for some ways and it's therefore exams in the,
in the process.
And I taken the first one while cooking at that first restaurant in Arizona.
So just so we can just,
so we can lay out that for people,
what are the four tests?
There's an introductory lecture and exam and that's not a very hard test.
Um,
but you,
you have to know a little something.
Um,
if you're a quick learner,
you can pick it all up in the lecture.
Then there's the certified,
they give you a lecture and then they test you on what's in the lecture.
Yeah.
Got,
ideally you've read something before you get there are,
you know,
you have more than a passing interest.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
that's an course slashing seem,
that's very much meant to inspire.
Like,
hey,
here's the cool world of wine and if you're into it,
you're going to read about it,
check it out,
build yourself a plan to acquire the knowledge and then come back and see us for
more exams as you go.
So,
so that's the first one.
The second level is the certified exam because there is an organization that's
called the court of Masters,
the court of Master sommeliers.
Okay.
Court of Master sommeliers.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Um,
different than the master of wine.
Those are there to,
um,
organizations are certifying bodies.
Yeah.
To Patty anally for diving's.
Exactly.
It exactly it.
Which are you?
I am patty.
I'm the other.
Yeah.
So this podcast is over now.
Um,
so anyways,
I'd taken it.
Oh yeah.
Right.
So certified exam is the second step and that was necessary because people are
like,
oh miss somebody,
Yay.
I passed the first exam.
And just from the court's perspective,
and I'm,
I'm not intimately involved with it,
um,
on day to day basis,
but it people are going to use this as a,
this is the standard and I am now this.
Then we felt like we actually ought to make it a real standard.
So we inserted the,
the certified exam where you have to be proficient in certain elements of wine
service and you know,
champagne service,
old decanting wine service,
all these sorts of things.
Um,
so that's level two.
Level three is the advanced exam,
which is indeed really,
really hard.
And it's three days of examination.
There's a blind tasting exam where you blind taste six wines.
And I don't mean blindfold,
you just walk into a room and there's six glasses with wine and them and you
have no idea what they are until you sit down.
And get after it.
Um,
so six months in,
25 minutes,
you know,
what are they,
how specific do they expect you to yet?
I,
you know,
if it's,
um,
Ridge Lytton springs,
infidel from 2010,
you should come up with,
hey,
this is infidel,
California,
north coast,
2010.
You should be,
you don't have to say rich,
but you got to get,
you're not that far off.
Exactly.
Okay.
Um,
that's one part of the exam.
The second part is a theory examination.
Anything,
um,
that you eat,
drink or smoke could be on that exam.
That's a written paper.
Oh,
it's a written paper.
Yeah.
Well,
pardon me.
Multiple choice or in some,
in some is,
what would a hypothetical question on that,
what there's so many,
um,
that we all are sworn that we'll never,
oh,
I gotta eat,
drink or smoke.
Not A,
not a precise question.
We're just wondering like,
you could it be something about pipes or cigarettes or smoking or,
uh,
cigars predominantly.
And that's actually,
it's super DNF for that.
Deemphasize now.
And I'm not even sure that there are test questions that deal with it any
longer.
But at that time you need to know that she's,
the guard service is actually done from the left side.
Whereas everything else you've done in that test to that point,
wine service for example,
has done from the right side.
And you know,
it's things like that ring gauges which is,
which is right is wine service,
left leftist.
And then memorizing ring gauges of cigar sizes and like things that are for me,
completely worthless.
You know,
it's like the periodic table.
I learned it for a moment and I forgot it the next day to make room for
something different.
Let's say,
same thing about that with cigar ringside and that's the advanced,
well that's part two of the advanced part two.
Part three of the advanced is actually service.
So you walk into a room filled with um,
master som ways.
Ostensibly it's a restaurant situation and you go from table to table and
perform different tasks that you're asked to,
to do,
um,
and their heart.
And it's a real thing and it's amazing actually.
But,
um,
and then the fourth and final level is exactly that again.
But the volumes cranked all the way up.
And the,
uh,
the theory portion is not written.
It's oral.
Is that,
got it.
Is that the masters?
That's the masters familiar test.
Exactly.
There are just about 200 of us in the world today.
And you were the ninth person to pass it on your first attempt?
I was,
it's that,
you know,
I just got done bagging on my opiate when it comes to working in the kitchen,
but I definitely had myopia when it came to studying for that test.
We'll look,
we'll come back to that.
So the,
so you,
you're talking to the chef,
you want it to work for all along?
Yup.
And he's like,
so you've been getting into this wine stuff.
Yup.
And you give him the replay having already past the first year level of
examination.
Yup.
And then what?
And he says,
okay,
you cook well.
So do you want to be the same way or do you want to cook?
I was like,
you've never had a [inaudible].
He's like,
exactly right.
We're going to move the restaurant to the foothills and it'd be a bigger space.
We're going to have a 10,000 bottles seller and someone's got to fill it and
sell it.
You want to do that?
And I was like,
I absolutely want to do.
It was incredible.
First Godson.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
It was really amazing.
And you learn so much when you build your own list and you're responsible for
budgets and you work for a chef owner who are,
I mean chef owners are notoriously maniacal
and I'm friends with a lot of origin.
Yeah,
it's true.
They are.
Um,
so that was an amazing experience.
I'd walk in with my order sheet every week,
which is,
you know,
he had the standardized or sheet,
this is what I want order,
this is who it's from,
this is how much it costs,
how many bottles,
blah,
blah.
And it would be so well reasoned and I would have thought out everything and
everything would have been researched from a point of view.
Like how good is the wine?
How well is it going to age?
What if it doesn't sell?
What's its trajectory?
Does it pair with the food?
I guess asking for these sorts of things.
I was totally armed to the hilt and I'd go in there and I hand it to him.
He'd slide it across the desk to him and he'd sit there and put on his reading
glasses and looked down and pull out a pen and just start crossing things out
without even asking questions.
It was brutal.
Brutal.
Is it mostly pricing based the those that got crossed out and I think it was,
I think I approached that with the wrong philosophy.
Like I went,
this is exactly what we need and he probably thought I was coming with more.
No one ever get cut down to less,
which is what I ended up doing over time.
So you learned the lesson,
you learned to negotiate with the chef owner by actually bringing in a couple of
gimmes that you're happy to let go.
It's totally real obvious ones.
Expensive neon lights on them.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
And just watch him.
When you said if they don't sell,
does that mean just looking at return policies and things like that or how you
would resell them?
How they would age,
how they would age Heatherwood eight.
Yeah.
There's really no return policy,
you know,
in any real way.
So,
and it's funny,
I'll go look at lists now and you'll be like,
wow,
there's a whole bunch of,
you know,
2004 California Sauvignon Blanc.
Well,
yeah,
that's probably,
most of those are no good any longer because it's not something that from this
particular place is known to age well,
and someone was enthusiastic for it.
They bought a bunch,
but in reality that restaurant only needed two or buy one,
sell it out.
Then by the next like 20 Avocados at a time.
It's like,
that's exactly it.
That's exactly it,
you know?
But,
um,
if it's something that's meant to age or will improve and actually appreciate,
then it's,
then it makes some sense to do it.
Yeah.
So you're building this list,
you're getting wise to,
uh,
the sort of horse trading that you do with your boss.
Yep.
Uh,
what do you,
what are the,
what other things do you learn in that,
in that first one or it's one of my most humiliating experiences as a some way.
Uh,
I mean,
I remember the first time I even the table table one 10 walked down the stairs,
first one on the left and someone ordered a bottle of,
um,
Roman [inaudible].
So can you say that again?
Roman?
A cold tea ashes though,
which today is fantastically expensive in 1999 or it could have been fall of
[inaudible] 98 that was all like $448 on the wine list.
And I was trembling and I remember going to the table and my hands were
trembling and shaking and you know,
super nervous and,
and uh,
you know,
since then I've served bottles that 50 grand or a hundred grand and 50 grand or
a hundred grand and that all goes away.
But,
um,
but it was right,
it was not shortly after I sold that vary that I'd be nervous of an a $450
bottle of wine.
Yeah.
So that's not where the embarrassment came.
But that was the first one.
And then it was like a week later,
you know,
I was on a roll and we were selling these things that you know,
at a real clip,
really expensive things.
And it was an 85 Berenger specialists or Cabernet Sauvignon from Napa on the
table with an 85 Mouton Raul Shield,
which is a first growth Bordeaux from France from the big deal,
five big deal.
Chateau in Bordeaux recognizes one of the great wines of the world.
And this guy had a table of six,
the order both bottles at once.
He wanted him to serve side by side and they were just going to compare it,
enjoy these things.
And so I decant them both and serve them both as he wishes.
And then,
I don't know,
30 minutes later I go back to refill and of course I pour the Mouton on top of
the Berenger
and I'm going,
Oh boy,
this is going to be horrible.
And he just smiles and laughs and he looks at me and probably knows I have no
possibility of paying for this whatsoever.
And he couldn't have been more gracious about it and uh,
I thought it was going to die at that moment.
It was for sure.
Because I mean,
you come on how much we're both of those combined more than a thousand bucks.
That's a lot.
It's a lot.
Yeah.
And 99 and young someway it's like,
oh,
I shouldn't $169 on my suit.
There's my rent for the next four months.
Exactly.
The whole thing,
the whole thing and he couldn't have been more gracious with was actually the
real lesson.
And apart from like paying attention,
it was really about what does it mean to be graceful and thoughtful and,
and so on and so forth.
So that was,
that was an amazing moment.
I worked at that restaurant until 2000 and remember the guy who sold me that
bottle of wine that changed my life in Flagstaff.
In Grad School?
Yeah.
About 30 minutes ago.
The way you're talking about the bottle,
that was across route 66 exactly.
That one.
In the meantime,
he had gone to Aspen and taking the job with the little nail for sure.
The worlds,
one of the world's best places to drink wine.
What was the name again?
The in at the little Nell or just the,
the little nail.
Even just the nail it as it's commonly in ELL and ELL and Aspen,
Colorado,
right at the base of the mountain and ski in,
ski out.
It's an amazing spot.
Sounds incredible.
It's special.
Um,
so he'd been to so many there and um,
he was leaving to go become the same way at the French laundry and said,
hey,
I'm leaving.
You should apply for my job.
I was like,
yeah,
of course I'm gonna apply for a job.
Great.
And,
you know,
huge shoes to fill.
I had no idea what it meant to be an aspen.
And I mean,
the caliber of wine drinker at that time is like,
it's as big as it can be.
It,
it doesn't get any bigger.
It's,
it's an amazing place.
You mean in terms of the clientele,
Zachary,
like way over my head.
Um,
but I applied for the job and I'm flying to Aspen and we do the whole dance
there and I fly and meet the GM.
He's in Los Angeles for a day.
We meet there and then the food and beverage director comes to Tucson and you
know,
you saved your best suit all week for when she comes in and,
and uh,
and it was great.
And I got the job.
I,
they probably had no business giving it to me at that time,
but I got the job as it's suddenly a slash wine buyer at the little Nell where I
had no budget and had a ton of storage and everybody drinks everything.
And Yeah,
we sold a lot of really great,
you said you had no budget,
no budget by what you want and it was,
oh,
I see.
Okay.
Unlimited budget,
unlimited budget.
There was no one crossing things out across the desk from,
you just had to count it once a month,
which is also a reason not to go crazy.
But,
um,
it was outrageous and it very quickly,
I mean,
I very quickly,
I realized how big the shoes where I had to fill,
uh,
which is good.
I very much respond to pressure.
Um,
you know,
it's like if you want to get fit,
I signed up for an event,
I will run.
I don't want to suck.
What were the pressures like what,
what were some concrete realizations that you had?
Almost all the guests knew more than I did and that was intense.
That's a lot.
That's huge.
And so what that mean?
It means like sleepless nights,
read,
taste,
practice for the master Somme test.
Exactly.
And part of the tastings I did healthy education that's in a place I did have a
budget quote unquote.
It was an education budget,
open whatever you want and you know,
certain number over tasting.
Yeah.
So you can learn really quickly.
That's cool.
Yeah.
That came back to that.
What is the right way to taste when you're given an opportunity to like that?
Yeah,
I mean is there like palate fatigue?
Do you have to do,
is it just like kind of physical training where it's like you can overdo it?
You can definitely overdo it.
I don't really,
I think everybody can overdo it no matter how much you practice at it.
Um,
either some,
some obvious things like,
you know,
don't eat Jalapenos before you're going to go taste wine.
Don't,
don't mess up your receptors in any strange way.
Similarly,
walnuts or artichokes,
you know,
all those things while it's an art chokes,
contain tannins,
which dry out your palate and make,
make it feel strange.
That's very funny considering that.
But I just had before we started talking,
I know we're going to have a few things to drink and a bit was a iced artichoke.
Yup.
Oh Ferris.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Definitely not a good way to store your wine tasting.
Um,
so there are a few rules like that,
but for the most part,
it's the thing that you really have to have as a method.
And I spoke earlier about a context that's half of the program.
The other half of the program to do this well is you have to have a method.
And by that I mean you do the exact same thing every single time.
It's an experiment.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm a big fan of this.
I have a friend that articulated this,
um,
he's in the,
he's a winemaker in California and there's a,
there's all kinds of fun experimentation.
But if you don't control the variables,
you know,
what do you actually learn?
And so Terry wax is on about the importance of data,
not dogma.
And I,
I love that saying,
and so when you have this method,
it's really about collecting the data in the same way the every,
every single time.
And it,
and it's objective.
It's not subjective.
It doesn't start with,
do I like this one or don't I?
That happens when you decide what you're gonna put on your table,
but when you're trying to learn about wine,
it's not about you.
It's about doing the same thing every single time and collecting the same
observations.
And you're taking this down in a notebook or some.
Exactly.
What do you,
um,
so to someone who's listening,
it was like,
you know,
I'd like to give that a shot.
Yeah.
How would they go about it?
Potentially.
So well,
shameless plug is start with buying the scratch and sniff wine book.
Yeah,
I've uh,
I've read it,
I've mentioned it,
I've given it as gifts to people.
Yup.
Within that,
it's really a subset of the method that I use to get through the master
sommelier exam.
And that's looking at three main areas of wine.
And that's fruit,
earth and wood.
And essentially those three categories populate almost everything that you're
going to smell and therefore taste in wine.
So make the same observations every single time.
What are the fruit elements I smell?
What are the elements that could be in part of by wood,
if the wind was Asian,
would that I smell?
What are the earthy elements I smell?
And that's,
that's the place to start.
Right?
And you do it with what you,
what you smell and then with what you taste,
um,
beyond that you have to make observations on what you see.
You know,
you talk about color,
you talk about visual clues for alcohol levels and all these things lead you to,
or visual cues for alcohol levels.
Like legs,
legs,
exactly.
Legs,
tears,
whatever you want to.
How does it,
how does it,
how does it correspond?
So the slower the legs fall,
the higher the alcohol level.
Got It.
Assuming there's no sugar,
those are the,
I mean I'm going to mass be from here,
but then are sacrilegious,
it's the,
it's the drips.
Like if you swirl the wine.
Exactly.
It's the drips down the side of them.
Lastly.
Yup.
From the high point of the liquid,
what trips back down to the glass.
Those are the legs of the tiers.
And so it seemed counterintuitive to me when I first learned this.
Like,
well,
alcohol is thinner than water or,
or the fruit juice.
So why if you have more alcohol,
why would it run more slowly?
But there's actually this capillary action that,
that pushes it back up the side of the glass.
So it's,
and plus it's always evaporating,
condensing on the size of the glass.
So the more alcohol there is,
the slower those tears fall.
Right.
And the reason you want to know that is if you're going to be geeked out wine
tasters,
it talks about a wine making style.
It talks about an origin,
right?
So in Germany you'll have thick tears by virtue of the sugar,
but not by virtue of the ripeness.
It's a cold place.
Right.
Or even,
you know,
go through the Loire Valley in France and Sophia and blogging,
cabernet franc and all these very beautiful varietals.
But they don't,
they don't have much alcohol,
which is as it should be because it's not a warm place.
And you come to California in particularly this year where it's really a warm
place,
you're going to develop riper fruit,
which is,
you know,
riper fruit means more sugar,
which means more food for the yeasts and more potential alcohol.
And once the eat it and create the alcohol there,
there it is.
Right.
So is that,
would that be for instance why,
and I'm just kind of making this up on the spot,
but why you find like a lot of zinfandels and mall backs have a high alcohol
content.
Exactly.
These exact world ones.
Yup.
What would,
if people wanted to try now when you're taking this down,
let's get 'em sort of prescriptive on the tasting.
Okay.
How much,
how much wine do you do?
Drink it.
I know a lot of people spit when you go to the wineries do drink it.
And how do you taste like what's the,
you have a bottle of wine glass.
Yeah.
Pour yourself a glass.
The first thing you do is you,
you turn it over sideways and you don't want to spill it out away from you.
So tip the glass away from you and look down through the wine against a white
background and the color tells you a lot.
So we don't smell color and we don't taste color.
Um,
it's very important to know that.
But color is an,
is an indication of the varietals and potentially also the climate.
So pinot noir should have the,
the versatile meaning the type of grape,
the type of grip he was asked,
Cabernet Sauvignon,
Sauvignon Blanc,
whatever.
Exactly.
So cabernet Sauvignon is a thin or a thick dark skinned varietals.
So it's going to make a dark skinned red wine.
In fact,
if you bite any grape that you want to make red wine from in half,
it's white in the middle.
So all the color that in a red wine comes from the skins.
So be it as cabernets is thick and dark.
You're going to have the result and thick and dark or permit,
dark colored red wine.
Whereas Pinot noir is thinner and lighter in color.
And so you're going to have a lighter color wine.
It doesn't have any less flavor,
isn't worth less of your attention or interest is just different.
So the first thing you wanna do is look at that color and it should give you,
if you don't know what the wine is,
it'll give you a visual clue.
Like if it's light red,
well don't,
don't think about Cabernet,
right?
Start crossing it off your list.
It's about deduction.
Um,
but if you know it's Cabernet and it's light red boy,
then you might think something's wrong,
right?
Because that's not a typical color for it.
So the first thing you do is you look at it,
um,
and you look for color and you look for sediment.
You know,
it.
Is there anything solid in there?
He looked for gases at bubbling.
If it's red and it's bubbling,
there's kind of,
you know,
maybe two or three possibilities on the planet of what it could be.
Um,
including things like sparkling Shiraz,
which is totally gross and I don't drink.
Um,
but those visual cues tell you a lot.
And then if it starts to Brown,
if you,
if we assume our glass of wine is tipped away from us and we look out to the far
northern edge,
if it starts to Brown,
it tells you that potentially is made it an oxidative style.
So the wine saw some oxygen while I was being made or it's older,
and that's probably,
you know,
more common.
Um,
and let me ask you this.
So what happens to an avocado if you cut it and leave it on the counter?
It oxidizes it was brown.
It turns Brown.
Same thing with old bananas or whatever it is.
And so the same thing happens with wine.
It's just grapes,
right?
And so grape juice goes through the same process.
It starts to turn Brown.
So if you see that sort of British Browning at the edge of the glass,
you can start just from my,
it's like,
oh,
okay.
So it's showing signs of oxidation,
therefore it's older,
right?
And then you do the exercise you look at at the legs or the tears and um,
you can start to discern like what's the alcohol level.
And so that brings us back to the context.
So we'll take a quick tangent on that.
If you don't,
I can look at that and say,
okay,
those are medium,
medium plus viscosity based on how those tears fall.
Well,
you only know what medium plus viscosity is if you've had all the wines of the
world.
So that's the context,
right?
You got to have a method,
got to have a content.
You have to experience the extremes.
Exactly.
And the spectrum,
right?
So for everyone who wants to do this is your homework,
it means you just have to taste a lot of wine.
It's great.
And you do a no,
I've heard for instance that,
and I want to be corrected if this is not correct,
but that you should sort of take the first swish of wine and just rinse your
mouth with it because that's not the,
that's not the sip that you want to try to evaluate.
Is that necessary?
Uh,
incorrect?
Well,
it depends.
If you just brush your teeth,
you know,
you should just drink a whole glass.
Right?
But,
um,
yeah,
it's definitely first pallet impression is,
is not necessarily the right one.
So spend some time with it.
Um,
before you do that though,
you definitely wanna smell it.
The things that we really taste are sweet,
sour,
salty,
bitter.
And if we're fortunate,
this idea of Umami,
this savory jasmine just had Umami Burger last night.
I like it.
Very delicious.
Nice.
So,
um,
everything else we think we taste,
we're actually smelling and so it makes sense to smell the wine.
So when I smell the wine,
I always think about this acronym few,
which stands for fruit,
earth and wood.
And so you want to smell for those things and force yourself require diligence
to answer all three of those questions.
Don't just blow by it.
So you might pick up a wine and it's just like,
oh my God,
strawberries,
Raspberries,
cherries.
Great.
All right,
cool.
Let's taste it.
Well,
what about the earth and the would cause those are two huge pieces that inform
the wine.
I think give that intellectual value and make it complete and make you smart.
So I'm always come up with at least three fruits,
whatever they are.
And use your own,
use your own language.
There is no wind speed.
That's it.
So I guess to,
to do that,
you probably also have to get into the habit of tasting.
I mean,
you should taste every that have fruit,
earth and wood characteristics.
Totally.
Yup.
So I mean we can talk about,
talk about all kinds of things we can juxtapose to supercharge that process.
Um,
but you definitely got to do it.
What do you mean by juxtapose?
So if you want understand what is earth?
Okay,
well let's buy,
you know,
Napa Valley Cabernet and compare it to Cabernet from Bordeaux,
both the same gray,
but the place really makes a huge difference.
They're likely made in very similar ways,
their age in the same oak,
but it's that soil that gives the Bordeaux the earthy thing that,
that will isolate that for you.
Right.
That's pretty cool.
So if people wanted to say get a handful of reds and a handful of whites,
all of which were very different.
Yup.
Just to start developing this,
what would a,
what would a few choices being?
So let's think about three whites by German Riesling,
right?
There'd be no oak.
So that's an example of an oak free wine.
It will likely have a little residual sugar depending on what kind you buy.
Um,
which is really interesting because you say,
I don't like sweet wine.
Well that's,
this isn't about you right now.
This is about your learning right now to buy a pallet.
So,
um,
what you will learn there is that it's about balance.
And so the sugar will be balanced by acidity.
It's all about balancing anyone.
Um,
so you'll also have earth.
So in the German wine you'll Hudson the earthy,
you'll have a great example of balance with residual sugar and you won't have
any oak or woody characteristics and compare that to California Chardonnay,
which won't very likely have any earth.
Um,
it won't have the same level of sweetness.
It will have oak.
So you can start to say,
oh yeah,
there's that Caramel,
there's that vanilla,
there's that butterscotch,
that's the Oak,
right?
So then you can like put your finger right on that and then compare it to
something like,
um,
you know,
maybe French sauvignon blanc or even Bordeaux Blanc.
So which is Sauvignon Blanc and semillon together in a blend,
but it speaks to the place Bordeaux.
And so you will have oak like the,
um,
like the California Chardonnay,
but you will have earth like the German Riesling.
And so you,
you have little bits of each one.
And when you can triangulate,
that's when you start to get really smart.
Like,
okay,
that's the wood.
Okay.
That's where it smells like,
right.
When you're removing one element at a time.
Exactly.
Or examining one element of time.
What about for uh,
Rudd's red?
I would,
you know what the pretty interesting to do would be?
Um,
well I'm a big fan of same as we just chatted about same varietals from
different continent that can be pretty interesting if we want to do different
varietals.
Um,
you know,
do something like Dolcetto from Piedmont,
say in Italy there's lots of Great Schultz,
bad at remembering Italian wine names.
Yep.
So dual chateaus,
the actual,
the name of the grape.
And unlike most of the wines in Italy,
this is actually named for the grape and not the place,
not the region.
Exactly.
So,
but Joel Choteau is most frequently,
so it's a red wine,
but it's most frequently made in stainless steel or with the absence of new oak.
So you'll taste grape and you'll taste place earth,
but you won't taste any influence of wood.
And then why don't we,
you can even go right next door and a and drink Barbaresco or Barolo.
So same region,
different grape.
So you can identify with what that grape is about almost.
I mean 99% of the good cases,
definitely Asian oak in.
So you can feel what oak does there and you'll probably find a tie in,
in terms of the earth,
right?
So as long as they have like one tether to each other,
then then it makes it really useful to see like,
okay,
well what's different?
Right?
And then you grab a Zinfandel from,
from Napa Valley and there you'll see like,
okay,
the alcohol is really different and that,
what does that feel like?
And Oak will be different because it'll be new oak and maybe it'll be American
oak,
which tastes like dill,
you know?
Uh,
so,
so all these little things,
we just start to triangulate.
But you gotta you gotta keep notes and keep it organized in some way.
Actually don't keep notes physical any longer.
I just keep it in my head.
But you did keep physical notes for a long time.
I God,
stacks and stacks of notebooks.
They fell over,
they'd hurt you.
Other stuff,
that's all.
What is a,
what is one of your favorites?
Zinfandels just out of curiosity,
because I tend to like zinfandels.
Yeah,
I have,
well,
lots of favorites.
I love the wines of Charlie.
Um,
Turley.
Truly.
Yeah.
T u.
they're based in Napa.
They make Zinfandel from,
from all over.
Um,
and Christina Turley.
Uh,
it was Larry's Larry Turley who founded it.
It's his daughter.
She's working with Teagan Pos,
all aqua to make some of the really,
really special zinfandels from California.
And then Ridge is a classic.
Paul draper has been making wine at Ridge for north of 40 years.
Um,
and it's,
it's as blue is infidel can get.
Cool.
Yeah.
What are some underrated,
uh,
wines and to be,
I'd love to get as specific as possible just for people who were looking to try
some wines that perhaps they wouldn't be exposed to that haven't been sorta
overloaded.
Yep.
What,
uh,
what are some that you could bring up?
So pinot noir is all the rage,
right?
It's for sure an overindulged princess.
I am I,
there's so much sweet,
expensive,
unduly expensive Pinot noir that I look elsewhere,
but I look for that same set of characteristics and I call him the s words,
wines that are silky,
sexy,
supple,
soft,
um,
things are full of allure.
That,
and those are wines that appealed to me.
Um,
and peanut noir doesn't have a proprietary right to those as I described them,
Pino characteristics,
they happen in things like we're notch.
Um,
in fact,
I'm a huge proponent of Bernache and believe that it's just the warm climate
analogy of Pinot Noir.
So think about peanut with just a little extra warmth,
a little extra give.
Um,
but all those same s words and it's,
it's great.
It would be a specific ganache that people could try to find online to check
out.
Um,
I'm a big fan of Ruston ganache resident.
Yeah,
our u s d e n roses and they make a Christine's vineyard granola.
It's from the Barossa valley in Australia.
I spent a lot of time there.
Um,
but to me that Australia is a,
is a whole other thing,
um,
that we could talk about for days.
But that wine in particular exhibits so much elegance when Australia may be as a
country is not known for elegance
and where everything is.
I know I butchered that,
but my Kiwis friends,
I let her influence.
Um,
it's,
it's something very elegant and it punches way above its weight.
Very cool.
Yeah.
Uh,
what are some common,
we're going to talk about other things like,
um,
whiskey and Miss Gallon,
all,
all sorts of goodness.
But before we get to that,
what are some common misconceptions about one or old wives tales,
things that annoy you?
That's it.
That's an interesting question.
Um,
well the first one is that more expensive?
As better.
That's definitely not true.
I mean,
it's absolutely not true.
It's slight.
It's a,
the supply and demand thing,
um,
to a large degree.
And so you know why you know,
and hype,
you know,
that that Mouton that I poured the Berenger on top of,
20 minutes ago,
you know,
my most embarrassing simile,
a moment that,
you know,
on unreleased maybe 500 euros a bottle in Europe today before you even get it to
America.
Why is it,
how much money?
You know,
who,
who knows other than,
um,
I mean,
they make something like 20,000 cases of it.
That's a lot of why.
So why,
why does it cost that much money?
Because someone said,
hey,
this is the best thing in the world.
And so everybody has to have it.
Right.
But isn't it really,
but is it really worth that?
Right.
It's like fashion.
Exactly.
And importantly,
people,
I actually get asked that question a lot.
They say,
is this wine worth as much money?
I say,
well,
it depends on the individual.
I mean,
yeah,
it's an marketplace question,
not necessarily quality question.
100%.
Exactly.
And so for someone it might be worth it and for someone else it might not be.
Um,
but more expensive is definitely not better.
It's a big thing.
Um,
you holler if somebody wanted to apply a positive constraint to themselves where
they couldn't buy wine over x number of dollars.
Yes.
A and let's say this is somebody who's,
you know,
not,
not poor,
but makes $50,000 a year.
Yup.
Right?
So they're not extremely wealthy either.
Yup.
Super easy to do.
Yeah.
What is,
what is like the sweet spot,
right?
In terms of between 15 and 20 bucks,
15 and 20 bucks.
Yep.
Two to find a bottle of wine for under $10.
You probably don't want to drink it.
Yeah.
And I mean there are of course exceptions,
there's,
you know,
people get in the weeds,
they blow things out,
you know,
so on and so forth.
And so maybe you get a steal every now and again.
But as a rule,
it's very,
very hard to make something for under 10 bucks.
Um,
I mean,
you do it by using fermentation tanks or as large as a city block with
mechanically harvested grapes that were mechanically grown in a place that's
probably environmentally very bad.
I've seen this stuff in,
in process and it's,
it's gnarly.
Um,
and you won't have any connection to the land.
So between 15 and 20 bucks,
you can actually get real wine from real people.
Um,
it probably won't come from,
you know,
the fancy Appalachians,
but that's great.
I mean,
those are always there.
Who Cares?
You know,
go explore the margins and learn something and there there's so many thrills.
What's another wine between say 15 and 20?
We're in that range that people probably haven't tried that you would suggest
they give ago.
Um,
like I haven't had much grenache so I'm going to try some organized.
Please do you get a lot of guilt?
A lot of great ganache from Spain where it's actually for a long time,
the most widely planted red variety in Spain.
And so there's just tons of it.
Sometimes it goes by the name of Rio,
Huh?
Where it might be in a blend real.
Okay.
So real high is grenache with tempered O'Neil and little interest.
I really am a big fan of Johan.
Yeah.
We can drink white Rio.
How to no one and no one thinks about that.
And we say real hot and everyone thinks red but white were Johan can be great.
It can be super age where they can be very affordable.
Um,
I drink a lot of,
uh,
I drink a lot of Jose from the south of France.
That's 1215 bucks.
And I,
you know,
a new producer I'm really smitten with,
uh,
from the lower,
um,
name is Mohs,
the wines are made from the Shannon Blanc grape.
They're totally cheap,
20 bucks.
Um,
and amazing.
Really,
really,
I mean world class special.
I would drink them before pretty much any white wine from California for which
you could spend $300.
Wow.
Yeah.
Very cool.
Uh,
so I interrupted you though.
You're saying,
uh,
misconceptions more expensive as better.
And then you said,
I want to say you said color.
Oh yeah.
So color,
that was a real pet peeve of mine is a simile.
You opened bottle of something and pour the tastes and before the tasered even
tasted it would be like,
oh,
that's great.
Or Oh,
that's going to be terrible.
Completely based on the color.
And you know,
as we chat about,
you don't smell color and you don't taste color and color has no bearing on
quality at all.
Um,
so just because it's dark doesn't mean it's going to be good.
You know,
I'd much rather look at my beautiful date and smell and taste something
beautiful.
Then just be impressed by a big inky glass of whatever.
Yeah.
Um,
the only bearing color has is on the,
on the actual type of grape,
not whether it's good or not.
Bear with me one second.
My puppy is eating my documents.
The dog is literally eating my homework.
One Sec.
No,
it's all good.
All good.
All right.
So we are,
we are still rolling.
Uh,
so we got the color and uh,
what else,
I mean,
I know you've,
you've said before that you think of wine as a grocery.
Yeah.
Could you elaborate on that?
Yeah,
definitely.
That's um,
that's also born out of that time living in Italy that the table's not set until
there's wine upon.
It might come out of a pitcher and poured into a tumbler,
but it's always their lunch and dinner.
It's on the table.
And I lived at when I was living there and I actually brought that back and live
it now.
Um,
and so that,
that's an idea that isn't a very American idea because we're,
we're so new in terms of,
of wine drinkers.
As a wine drinking community,
we're,
we're still so young.
Um,
but there it's well established,
um,
for centuries,
Millennia.
Um,
and it's that idea that wine ought to be a part of your everyday life.
It makes your life better.
And so,
yes,
I have this isn't that wine is grocery not a luxury
and I never,
this is embarrassing to admit,
but it had been in the bigger 15 years and I didn't become interested in wine
until I lived in Argentina for a year.
Awesome.
And wine was on the table every single meal.
Always everyone drank wine at dinner.
It was just that is part of the process.
It's like setting the table with a knife and fork.
Yup.
You put the wine on the table and then came back with a renewed interest in sort
of exploring,
um,
I mean similar to the Pinot Noir,
I feel like mall Beck kind of flooded the market,
totally became very popular and is as a result people could get away with sort
of murder in terms of low quality and high prices,
but the have been exploring more.
I just liked the,
the,
the really kind of fruity high alcohol content actually in and uh,
you know,
Carmen areas and whatnot.
But um,
you know,
you have expanded though since,
uh,
all of your time in the wine world that I'm sure there maybe they're similar
languages.
Like wine is Spanish and Whiskey is Portuguese.
But we have,
we have,
we have a bunch of bottles sitting behind me.
Should I go grab those?
We should.
Okay.
And Six classes and six glasses.
All right,
so we're going to pause this and go get a number of things,
a number of tools to have alcoholic.
We'll be right back.
So we're laying out six glasses.
I asked what type of glasses and the,
the answer was they really just need to be large enough that you can smell.
So,
you know,
like a sock aid glass wouldn't be large enough.
But I'm using for those people interested beakers because I'm a Weirdo and I
like to scare people who come over for dinner and to thinking that it might be
drinking out of something I put urine in previously.
There are 250 milliliter,
Kai Max Kimball beakers and 250 milliliters is exactly one third,
a bottle of wine,
a standard bottle of wine.
And I love these glasses.
I was first exposed to them at a place called the flour and water.
Uh,
and I'm actually an investor in that groups,
uh,
one of their other restaurants called central kitchen in San Francisco,
but they,
they used beakers and they also use speakers for candles.
Okay.
And that is,
that is all,
we have a lot of booze laid out in front of us.
I'm excited about this.
And uh,
the,
um,
okay.
The whiskey story,
I mean,
how did you segue?
I'll let you finish this.
The last porks we have six of these.
Uh,
but I'd love to hear how you segwayed
from wine to whiskey wharf.
That's always been present.
No,
it's definitely a segway.
It's,
I think of my job as to help people enjoy their lives.
And I think we do that by helping people find easy ways to get smart about
things,
which can then increase their air enjoyment.
Frankly.
You know,
mine was scary.
So we write a scratch and sniff wine book that makes it not scary.
Yeah,
knock it off the pedestal.
Make it easy,
make it accessible,
and tell people that it's actually super democratic.
It's up to you.
What's,
what's good.
It's not up to me,
you know,
don't,
don't drink them because I said drink it.
Drink something because you figured out that you like that.
Right.
That's,
that's the key.
Um,
and so in,
in creating that,
that book,
you create a methodology and,
and it's again,
breaking it down into its component pieces.
It's just like dissecting a frog.
Like,
okay,
where's this?
Where's this?
Where's this and how do they make the thing tick?
Um,
and we did that with wine.
So you understand that it's again about fruit and earth and wood and those,
those things populate all the smells that you're gonna smell and then you can
put them back together in whatever order you want to make,
what you want,
you know,
make what you want to drink,
what'll make you happy.
Um,
and that same methodology applies to whiskey.
there are some things tuition doesn't apply.
Like I don't think it applies very well to beer,
particularly with the explosion in craft brewing.
Why is that?
Because the place part has been so obscured and so now with,
um,
you know,
we can make a beer in California.
Exactly.
Yeah,
yeah.
The origin part.
So whereas years ago I think
it really mattered.
Um,
we would say,
okay,
well this has to be Belgian.
And because you recognize certain flavors that come from certain yeasts that
only happened in this place,
but now those are imported here and there's all kinds of souring techniques and
things that people do to really obscure place.
So it doesn't,
it doesn't apply to beer,
but it applies really well to whiskey.
Now whiskey.
Uh,
I'm cheating a little bit here.
This is because I know the answer but I was so excited to see this cause I've
always felt like a dumb ass when trying to write the word whiskey with or
without an e at the end.
It depends on the country of origin and that's it.
So it's a great,
it's a great rule.
It's w I s k.
Y if you,
if the whiskey comes from a country that doesn't have an e in the name Scotland,
Scotland,
Japan.
If it comes from a country and Canada,
if it comes from a country with an e in the name Ireland or America and it's
spelled w,
Pretty cool.
I love that.
I love that truck.
It's,
it's very,
very cool.
There's,
there's another one.
This is a,
this is just for people like me who are maybe a little slow perhaps born in a
place like long island like I was,
I always forget
this may reflect how ill suited I am to something like a master Somme test.
But I always forget which bread is mine in which water is mine.
Yeah.
So I,
I'm stealing bread.
I'm drinking other peoples drinks.
And if you,
if you touch your index finger to your thumb on both hands,
like you're making an okay symbol,
your left hand will make a B.
That's bread in your right hand.
We'll make a d,
which is drink.
And that's what I will do under the table sometimes when I'm unsure of which to
crack to my love that that's super smart.
And then fork or if you're setting a table fork knife,
it's the letter of,
it's the number of letters.
So a fork is four letters left is four letters.
So they,
they,
they fit on the side associated with the number of letters.
I,
let's uh,
so,
so you're talking about whiskey.
So a lot of the wine is few is whiskey,
also few.
It is fruit,
earth and wood.
And so,
um,
but it's,
but the fruit in this case isn't fruit as an a grape.
It's grain.
Right.
And so the first thing that affects the outcome of Whiskey,
I mean,
the first thing to know about whiskey is this just distilled beer.
That's it.
Like you take beer and you put it in a still and you turn on the heat,
not too high,
but just high enough so that only the alcohol evaporates,
right?
Because it evaporates at a lower temperature than water.
And then you condense it and you capture that on the other side of this thing.
And you've separated the alcohol from the water and genius,
it's called distillation.
Um,
so what we put in at the beginning is just beer.
So you make your beer and what do you make the beer from?
Makes a big difference.
Um,
predominantly corn,
wheat,
rye and malted barley are the,
are the four big grain type cereal.
Cereal grains are used
to make that beer to become whiskey.
Um,
in America,
corn is king.
Um,
and now rye is,
is sharing the stage as well.
But if you're drinking,
bourbon has to be at least 51% corn.
Now I'm going to,
I'm going to ask is,
uh,
an embarrassed yet.
Another embarrassing question.
What is the difference between Bourbon and whiskey?
Is Bourbon a subset of whiskeys that are regional name for whiskey?
It's,
um,
so bourbon has set of laws,
has to come from America.
It doesn't have to come from Bourbon County,
Kentucky,
as,
as there is a Bourbon County,
Kentucky,
but we make bourbon all over the country.
So it has to come from America.
It has to have been made from at least 51% corn.
So the balance can be that Rye,
it can be the wheat,
whatever.
Um,
and it has to be aged in charred new oak barrels and charge.
Yeah.
So you,
you fell a tree,
you cut the tree into planks,
or in this case they're called staves.
And then you bend them using heat to make a barrel,
and then you actually char the inside of the barrel with a flame.
And when you do that,
it obviously it changes its color,
but it also pulls that all kinds of flavors and caramelizes things in that tree,
which also contribute flavors.
So it's that,
you know,
it's the brown sugar if the Brown spices like cardamom and cinnamon.
Um,
it's the Nela,
lots of vanilla,
butterscotch.
All those flavors come from that oak barrel.
So if you age it in that barrel and it's made from 51% corn,
you did in America,
you have bourbon.
That's Bourbon.
Yup.
Cool.
So didn't want to interrupt.
So the,
the,
the main options again,
key role through that.
You've got corn,
wheat,
Rye and malted barley,
malted barley.
What is molted meter?
So it means you,
you sprout it and you know,
just like we would eat sprouts,
you know,
they,
the sprout the grain and then you arrest that process so you,
you kill it essentially with heat.
Um,
and so they,
it's a big deal and scotch production.
Um,
and in Japanese whiskey production as well.
So what a scotch.
So Scotch is any whiskey that comes from Ireland.
Ah,
Harmeet,
Scotland,
and of course Irish whiskey coming from Ireland.
Got It.
Okay,
cool.
This is making a lot more sense now because I,
I've never really felt
confident.
I think part of it is that I'm usually drunk when I'm trying to have these
conversations,
but to have a whiskey conversation,
which has been actually a handicap for me in some cases because I spend quite a
lot of time in Japan and they love their whiskey and well,
I mean it doesn't help that we're also speaking Japanese,
but uh,
so what,
so what are we looking at here?
We have similar,
looking at a Bourbon for Jack Daniels.
We're looking at e h Taylor,
a rye,
which is so whiskey made in America,
but rise predominant grain.
You're looking at Jamieson straight up Irish whiskey.
We're looking at a nica Takut soro 17 year old Japanese whiskey.
Yup.
Um,
we're looking at Edward Hour,
which is low lower part of the highlands in Scotland,
a region in Scotland,
a whiskey,
but mainland Scotland is the key.
Um,
so Azure dour 10
year old and we're looking at Ardbeg,
um,
specifically,
it's called [inaudible],
which is a,
it's a scotch made on the island of Islah,
which is off the coast.
And so very different than mainland Scotland because you're right on the ocean.
And so we'll see in the six glasses that the difference that grain contributes
and we'll see the different types of oak and what that contributes and then how
place really influences the final product.
Cool.
I'm going to,
I'm going to go grab a camera because I want to take a photograph of this for
folks.
Before we get into it,
could you please describe or explain the tattoos that you have?
Why do you have the tattoos that you have and where do they have?
So on my right arm is a dandelion.
It's a love note to a woman named Carla [inaudible],
who I love more than I've ever loved anybody.
Actually.
It didn't think it was possible.
It's great.
Uh,
and she has something very,
very similar,
very similar to analyze Candyland.
Why a dandelion,
you know,
it's,
I,
I'm a big fan of how a dandelion changes so rapidly through its life.
And I loved the part where it ends up with a great big shoot and it actually
depends on the wind to disburse it seeds.
I think that's just a,
it's a beautiful,
quiet,
profound thing that poetic.
Yeah,
it's really,
really pretty.
And uh,
put a left arm.
It's a collection of memories of and of things that,
that have made me happy,
um,
over time.
And there's Mount Vesuvius,
which I had probably the most amazing single day of my life on.
Um,
where is that?
It's just off of,
of Naples and central southern Italy.
Um,
there's a fish on a bun,
so think of Fish Burger and a mermaid and a heart and that's an Ode to a
mermaid.
I fell in love with Carla.
Uh,
fell in love with eating fish on a bun,
sandwiches at the cup and saucer diner on the corner of canal and Eldridge in
Chinatown in Manhattan.
Um,
there's a seashell with some,
uh,
sea critters in it that are from a,
um,
a story I spun for my daughter called Samuel the sea cucumber and he and his
friends managed to travel around the entire globe,
um,
in a sea shell tethered to a piece of seaweed and we use it as a,
as a lesson in a geography.
And this is a story that you made up or story that you read that I made up.
That's awesome.
I would spin it to her every night at bed.
And so just keep going.
And you know,
that's how the princess bride came to be.
Also.
That was a story that William Goldman would tell his I think might've been his
daughter or his son and then eventually put it down.
Oh,
that's awesome.
That's really great.
What's the 27 27 born in the 27,
27 is a lucky number for me.
And over and over and over it keeps repeating itself.
And in this case,
the red above the gold,
um,
are from an apartment that I shared with a Carla in Chinatown.
And there were actually three 27 from the building where they were just,
there was the original address and then I'll got painted over and they stuck
another 27 on it and 100 years later it had Patina and they stuck another 27 on
it and they just as beautiful,
such cool.
And he said it was very cool.
Be Nice,
be nice.
Um,
it's,
you know,
it started as a B and it was in there for 10 years all by itself.
Sbe No,
just,
just the letter B.
And it was,
it was,
it's kind of on the inside so it was a note to self to just be kind,
be thoughtful,
benevolent,
take your time,
just be a good guy,
you know?
And,
and sometimes I thrash about and it's a little reminder note to self.
Right.
Um,
and it just grew into be nice and just plain and simple.
What about the safety meeting and what is that?
So,
oh,
it's some type of a mythological creature between the safety and the meeting.
Yeah,
it's a dragon off with the corona bottle.
What's the story there?
It's a shout out of my homeys from the little nowhere.
We would have safety meetings if you were,
this is like one of the joys of restaurant work.
He'd be on the floor and you'd be in the weeds or someone be yelling at you
about something and you just look at your favorite waiter and we'd say safety
meeting.
And we both knew that meant walk into the kitchen,
walk into my white wine cooler,
lock the door from the inside,
pound a corona,
walk back out on the floor and rock service.
Very
[inaudible].
See if team meeting,
uh,
I was just talking to someone who shall remain unnamed but very,
very high performer and uh,
uh,
he,
he with his friends would have,
they'd have some harebrained question that usually had dangerous implications
and they would say,
well,
let's play,
let's find out was let's play the game of,
let's find out.
So good.
Oh,
so I,
I interrupted you the cause I was,
I want to take photos of this for people and for those people,
go to the show notes and you'll get,
you'll find links to everything we're talking about,
but you also find the photographs.
Who does,
that's just four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and click on podcast.
And you'll also see photographs of some of the audio gear that I'm using here.
But,
um,
so I'm excited about this.
So what's,
what's the next step then?
So the next step is you're going to smell the first,
which is Jack Daniels Bourbon.
Okay.
And the second,
which is the e h Taylor Rye.
Okay.
Am I,
am I looking for anything in particular or just impressions?
So the real thing here is,
okay,
so they're both aged and new charred American oak,
not,
they're both made in America and Asian America.
So wood in place are relatively equal.
The big difference is that the Bourbon is 51% at least corn and the rye is rye.
And so when we talk about what are the three things that inform a whiskey while
the first one is grain,
and that's what I want to illustrate for you here.
I'm,
hopefully you can smell the difference.
The Rice should be more pungent and spicy.
Okay.
Let's see.
One moment folks.
He's got his nose all the way in that beaker.
This is like golf commentary like Yup.
Oh yeah.
It's crazy,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it's a huge difference.
Yeah.
To rise actually.
Classically,
I mean it's been around forever,
but also it's using a Manhattan.
Yeah,
it's got,
it has almost like a,
a more of a pain like bite to it.
Okay,
so that maybe not paint,
maybe it's paint thinner that I'm thinking of her like a Turpentine,
you get that barn.
She thing with protracted aging in a barrel so it does take,
take that on.
So that's a function of time.
I spend time.
Got It.
The spice from the grain itself should also be there and you know it plays in
the same,
in the same area.
When I smell things,
I think about it a lot like musical ranges.
And so the base,
you know,
hangs out down here and there's rich things like chocolate and the vanilla can
happen down in there.
Sometimes.
A question,
does it ever take your nose time to warm up?
Cause I feel like I just smelled this like the fourth time and I'm getting a lot
more from 100% is that as another key would be open your mouth.
When you smell,
everyone likes slams,
their mouth shut and you actually get less information.
It's really open to,
what is it called?
The retroactive retro nasal hot.
Damn it,
it was so close,
but it makes a huge difference.
And don't,
you know,
for those of you listening,
don't like take a hard pull on it,
like you do wine or it'll actually really burn.
So with spirits you can smell really gently.
Yeah.
The alcohol will want to give yourself a alcohol awry.
Nasal irrigation.
Yeah.
So I mean it almost smells like a Rye bread.
Which is so interesting that that actually comes through.
Yeah,
it does.
You're right.
Yeah.
And then this guy,
the,
the Jack Daniels just smells her suite and round and it doesn't have any of that
same spice.
So that's the first piece.
Grape.
The next piece,
we're green in this compartment.
Grain exactly.
Of Grape and grain.
My favorite.
That's,
that could be,
it could be your next book title.
It should be,
um,
well we have to throw a Gavi and they're so succulence.
Um,
the next is Irish.
And so as Jamieson and just straight Jamison,
which is a brand going crazy,
but what makes Irish,
Irish,
and I just want you to think about it as it compares to the things before,
is that I'm frequently,
they distill more than twice,
three times.
Um,
and the farther you go with the distillation or you can even use a column still,
which means not bother ourselves with the point is the farther you go with the
distillation,
the more you take out of it.
Right?
So if we start with our beer is a hundred liters and we distill it,
we ended up with,
I don't know what,
at 30 liters.
And if you distill that again,
maybe now you're at 15 liters and he was still at again and now you're at seven
and a half liters.
Is it subsequently removing more of the characteristics that make it unique?
And that's exactly what you're getting closer to rubbing alcohol.
That's 100%.
You're all over vodka essentially.
So it has nothing to say,
um,
that has something to say,
but it's not saying it very loudly.
So that's a very Irish thing to do.
This is like the Catholic school version,
exact last spoke when spoken to a hundred percent,
hundred percent.
So it's,
it's um,
it's,
this is where process is a function of place.
And so this is typically what happens with the vast majority by volume of,
of Irish whiskey idea.
Why they do that.
Because I would,
I'm just thinking back to like Ireland,
potato famine.
Why would
they take such a high volume of stuff and make it smooth and make it,
make it so much smaller?
Reducing.
Yeah.
Now it's a,
it's a great question.
Um,
I think it was really a matter of,
of what people favored in terms of drinking.
And so it's so different than Scotland in,
each of them were competing for the royal favor.
You know,
what are,
what are people gonna drink and what's going to be the drink?
Right.
They're very,
very different and they've each enjoyed popularity at different times.
So Jamieson [inaudible].
This should bring back some memories for me because I remember being in Dublin
and this was in for those of you who read the four hour work week,
this was in 2000 late 2004 I had just landed,
I was in London than Ireland was recommended,
landed in Dublin and later they said,
what the hell are you doing in Dublin and should go to Galway and that's how I
ended up there.
But the,
I got really into hurling and getting sponsors,
the senior sort of nationals and the competition for this,
for those who haven't seen hurling,
not the puking game that's also popular in Ireland,
but it's the fastest field sport in the world.
It's like Lacrosse plus baseball with axe handles on a soccer field.
It's extremely violent.
Fantastic game.
But I want to take a tour of the Guinness Factory as a result.
I was just curious.
I don't really drink beer.
Yup.
Got on a bus.
It was a hop on hop off bus,
got to the Guinness factory or a brewery I suppose.
Massive as you'd imagine.
And the line was,
this was probably nine 30 in the morning and the line was just hundreds of
people now.
And I opted out.
I was like,
Nah,
I don't even really drink beer.
If it were easy,
I would do it,
but no thanks.
A few stops later,
the Jamison distillery shows up and I'm like,
okay,
sure,
let's check it out.
I go in and they go,
okay,
well for later we're going to need a few volunteers and raise my hand.
They pick maybe two or three of us and later we have to do a tasting,
but a marathon tasting.
And so all of us wander out at like 10:00 AM completely shit faced.
Awesome.
That was my introduction to Jameson.
I love it.
So am I,
should I smell for anything in particular?
I think just relative to the last one.
So again,
this is like developing your context and I mean I have some things that I
attribute to Irish whiskey,
um,
but I would rather you smell unfettered.
Ain't no,
it's a very subtle part here.
Let us just a little bit.
Yeah,
it is subtle.
Exactly.
God,
I'm getting anxious.
Like a school child who Nada the exam naked.
No wrong answer.
It's that,
that's the whole key to this is that you just use your own vernacular.
I had a DVD that I have a deviated septum on one side of my,
in one nostril,
which has been bothering me for years.
Uh,
but I just thought I was at a stuffy nose.
Okay.
I know that it's,
it's much understated compared to the other two totally but are not sure.
And so why is vodka so popular?
Because it doesn't taste like,
you know,
and you can mix it with things.
So that subtlety and it's Amie ability make it actually quite popular for
flexible,
very flexible,
very easy to drink.
Um,
it's a little bit lower proof than the rye porridge you,
um,
you know,
more percentage alcohol.
Um,
so for me that,
that comes from the process associated with the place,
you know,
keep distilling,
you keep thinking,
taking things out.
It has less to say and it's means.
So it was kind of grassy,
kind of urby and a little bit of like a honey thing maybe.
But you know,
those are just personal adjectives.
What would it,
I mean,
have you found,
is the nose like
height,
meaning like you are born with a certain knows and uh,
it's,
it's maybe malleable a little bit,
but not very,
or is it like muscle where you can develop it?
I think it's totally trainable.
My Dad's a great example.
He was like,
I can't smell anything.
And you know,
and her sons getting into wine and now he can smell everything and it's just,
it's like a radio.
You just have to tune it in.
Right.
And once you get there,
um,
I think it fits a greedy.
I'm like my dog,
I've stuck my nose right into it.
It's,
um,
you know,
when,
when we were hunter gatherers,
we depended on this scent of smell for life.
Right?
You know,
I can eat that or I can't eat that.
That's rod and that's poison,
whatever it is.
And it's,
we don't have to rely on it at all to the same degree.
So it's the first of the senses that we tune out.
And so when you get into this,
it's a matter of just tuning in back in.
I think part of that is the amount and the frequency with which we eat.
When I,
I've done a number of fascinating experiments and for instance,
I just fasted,
I broke a fast last night,
so I fasted for,
uh,
the short fast for me,
like 48 hours.
Okay.
And your evolutionary biology upgrades,
your smell immediately,
like whatever brainpower is dedicated elsewhere is suddenly harnessed for the
nose.
It's really interesting.
That's super cool.
Very,
very cool.
They do that for a falconry also.
I understand it is.
If they're doing hunting or any type of precision work with Falcons,
they will,
lab starves a hard word,
but they'll restrict their food so their senses are sharpened.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Pretty good.
Uh,
yeah,
if you guys want to see something crazy,
you can watch falconry in Mongolia where they hunt deer with falcons.
Uh,
so what's,
let's see,
we were here.
Yup.
The Jameson,
we're gonna leave Ireland and we're going to go to Japan.
And so the Japanese model is very much based on the Scotch model,
which you're going to have in the last two glasses.
Um,
so malted barley.
So this is really a single malt when it's a single mall or you read that on a
bottle,
just means that it's made from malted barley.
The Jamison,
what are the grains and the Jamison?
Um,
so barley,
wheat,
rye.
Okay.
No corn.
That makes sense.
I,
you know,
they're born could be corner here,
but it's definitely the primary.
Exactly.
And then the Japanese is the malted barley is malted barley.
And so those guys took their cues from Scotland as to how to do,
and they're very much trying to,
to your tried to emulate what they did in Scotland,
but it happens to Japan.
So it has,
the place factor is a,
is a big,
big difference.
And I always get some,
um,
for me it feels you have a much deeper understanding of Japan than I do.
But I,
I always find things to be very subtle and very beautiful and very complicated,
but not outwardly.
So it's not Austin tissue.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Um,
so I love Japanese with smells delicious.
It smells very floral to me.
Yeah.
So that's it.
You're right on it.
Tim's actually great taster.
Give me,
I appreciate the pad on the podcast to your bag,
but I got the floral.
Uh,
so that's,
that's definitely is also love barley.
So one of my favorite things,
the part of the reason that I'm liking this artichoke tea that I'm keeping cold
Yup.
Is I really became a fan of huge fan of barley tea.
I think it's barley tea.
Mcgee Cha.
Yeah,
go for it.
Uh,
there's a tea called [inaudible],
m u g I cha is just t c h a,
c h,
a.
W.
It's like,
you know,
if you have,
even in Chinese it's the same like Oo Long Cha Cha is the same thing,
but the Mcgee Char,
they,
they use in the summer and drink cold.
Cool.
Uh,
so they,
there barley's is used elsewhere in Japan,
but I get a very,
yeah,
you guys should try that out if you have the chance.
Uh,
or you can trust them if some children artichoke t without anything else.
But,
uh,
I really liked the smell of this.
And this is,
what is this called again?
So this is from a Nika and it's specifically Taketsuru Taketsuru and 17 years
old kids that it's like Tuck it to do is like,
uh,
bamboo crane.
I think somebody can correct me here,
but so do I think is crane.
It might be heron,
but pocket is,
uh,
I think it's like she talk it or no,
maybe those are two different,
uh,
that maybe isn't the mushroom but bamboo.
That's cool.
That's very cool.
It's very cool.
Well,
that floral thing you hit on and sometimes referred to as the old temple and
this whole whiskey temple see incense,
Cedar and Sandalwood.
Oh,
what an amazing smell.
Isn't that cool?
That smells really good.
So that's made a whole lot like this next one is made,
entered our front is dot Edward Hour.
Had a hell do you spell that?
E.
Spell it.
[inaudible].
Got It.
And so that's from mainland Scotland.
So the big variable here is place.
Right?
And so all things being equal,
you've got Japan versus mainland Scotland.
Yeah.
Okay.
Very different.
So differently.
Different.
Right.
Okay.
God,
you know,
I need to smell more things.
I need to like follow my puppy around and smell everything or most things,
not everything my puppy likes.
I'd like,
I'm having a really tough time penny down,
but it has a very,
very particular scent to it.
What would you,
Oh man,
it's fun to poke at it.
And then when,
when all of you are at smelling,
they shouldn't,
you shouldn't rush.
I would say one of the great joys of smelling and tasting things and if I had to
pick one particular moment,
um,
I,
first time I smelled of Rutherglen Muscat,
Muscat dessert wine made in Ruther Glen Australia and I'd never had one before.
And I picked it up and I smelled the glass and immediately I was back in fifth
grade afterschool running through my grandmother's front door and she just
pulled ginger snaps out of the oven.
And that memory,
I mean,
I was 35 years old when that happened.
And like the Ratatouille in the movie one Anton Ego.
It's the routed to exactly.
So it's a cool but and so however old each of us are,
we have that many years of memory based on smell.
And it's so cool to let those just come floating back to you.
I can't pin this down.
I want to say it's like a very dark chocolate or something.
But I,
I'm with you.
Yeah,
I,
I can't,
I can't quite nail it.
It's a very familiar smell to me that isn't Scotch.
But what would you,
I mean,
how would you describe this?
What descriptors would you use?
For me,
this is,
this is actually quite rich and it's actually,
it does have this sort of malted milkshake thing,
the vanilla park,
but it also has a lot of oak on it.
So it does have that richness that almost milk chocolate caramel,
the Nela.
That's a thing.
I mean it's,
it's pretty round and voluptuous for Scotch.
I stuck a milkshake as I kind of milkshake type smell too.
Exactly.
So what did they put in the milkshake?
Just Malt.
That's true.
That's all from the milkshake.
That's smells like the mall.
That's what I'm associating on.
Right.
Because I've had more milkshakes and I have had scotch if Nicole that is cool.
That's super cool.
Okay,
so the last glass,
same country,
Scotland,
but now you're out on an island where the,
the cast,
so this is really about place.
And so,
so same process in terms of making this stuff,
um,
in terms of distillation and cask gauging,
but were cascading.
Yeah,
exactly.
But when you're a type of wood or the aging and end,
so great question.
Used barrels from Jack Daniels amongst other bourbon producers and you Sherry
barrels.
So from the south of Spain,
use Madeira barrels from the island of Madeira and Sherry barrels are made out
of what type is that also oats.
All Oak to all.
Okay.
And so if you,
or any type of cascading that is not done in Oh yeah,
there's a chestnut,
which is common in northern Italy,
but that's,
that's more for wine.
Got It.
Got It,
got it.
Exactly.
All right,
so these,
this all happens by the ocean.
So there's the use of Pete.
This last one.
Yeah,
exactly.
So place matters a lot here because Pete is used,
um,
in a really profound way.
So when we malt the barley,
right,
you're taking the borrower,
you're getting it wet,
you're letting it sprout,
and then we halt that sprouting process with heat and the heat comes from
burning peat.
And so in this case,
in this case,
Alaska on the island.
Yeah.
What is it's a moss,
right?
Or,
yeah,
it's,
it's essentially a stage short of coal.
So it's compressed dead grass,
dead moss and it sorts of,
uh,
cut it out in like bricks of really dark looking Adobe almost you're saying.
So it's like cow dung that you would burn for fuel and Mongolian eight.
Interesting.
So that flavors it,
but then also you age these casks by the Se side.
Yeah.
Okay.
I get things like in addition to smoke iodine brine salty.
Yeah.
It does have a briny.
A briny uh,
Bryony smell to it.
Okay.
So different,
isn't it crazy?
Yeah.
That's cool.
This is fun guys.
You should definitely do this.
Um,
is the short strokes with it.
So you just put some things next to each other.
And you can really supercharge your learning since,
okay.
So what is place do well,
you've just seen,
what does OIC do?
Well,
you've just seen,
you can treat it like a workout.
I mean,
you treat it like an actual learning session.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So you're sort of separate the recreation from learning,
even though you can transport the learning then to the enjoyment by exactly.
Keep the training separate.
So,
uh,
what's next?
What's next?
Uh,
we release a book on this stuff.
What's next as it relates to me with this,
this,
this plethora of drinking,
drinking.
How would you know?
So I have six of these.
Yes.
In front of me.
Any particular order?
I would go in the same order that we taste it.
Actually,
no,
I'm going to put the Irish first.
It has the least to say.
Let's start.
There was the lightest it got it.
Okay.
So this is the Jamison.
There was the Jameson.
Exactly how much when you're tasting something like this,
um,
you know,
just a little bit enough to get it down your throat,
I think.
Um,
you know,
you see a lot of wine tasting,
everyone's spirits and so on and so forth,
and you should,
I mean,
first of all,
I want to advocate responsibility.
That's important.
You got it.
You got to do what's right for you.
But if you're really going to get the information and you have nowhere to go,
you got to swallow a little bit because you feel certain things in certain parts
of your mouth and they're also taste receptors.
Yeah.
Outside of the mouth.
A lot of people don't realize this and all the way down to the stomach even or,
I mean further through the Gi process.
Yeah.
Okay.
Since your first of the day,
see you probably feeling the alcohol.
Yeah.
But beyond that,
you know,
what do you feel?
Oh God,
I just feel like I lack the vocabulary here and be,
I'm being asked to name musical notes,
but I don't know how to read sheet music.
Don't you don't read sheet music.
He's your own vocabulary.
Okay.
This is like for those of you who've seen the chess lesson between Josh Waitzkin
to myself,
it was an extra for the Tim Ferriss experiment.
My face,
uh,
looks about the same right now.
Uh,
the Irish should really have an answer and I don't have an answer yet.
It doesn't really have a lot to say.
I it tastes kind of boozy and it tastes kind of thin and there's not a whole lot
that's,
that's okay.
That's pretty much what I would say.
Yeah.
I don't have a lot more to add to that.
Totally.
I mean,
you could add ginger ale and maybe make it,
there's nothing wrong with Jamison,
but you know,
point,
point being like,
you know,
that's why it gets mixed with things.
Got It.
Okay.
And Jack Daniels.
Jack Daniels,
and this is seven.
Yup.
Got It back to me.
Well,
corn,
essentially it's 10.
It's Tennessee whiskey.
Tennessee whiskey.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what's the difference?
That's,
this is a question while you're tasting the difference between Tennessee whiskey
and Bourbon,
um,
is that Tennessee whiskey actually does have to come from Tennessee.
Hmm.
Um,
and it has,
if you come from Tennessee,
you actually have to go through this other thing called the Lincoln county
process where they filter the booze through a 10 foot column of charcoal,
and that just takes out impurities.
And so it makes it smoother,
right?
But essentially the,
the Tennessee process,
apart from that,
that filtering and Bourbon are very,
very similar.
So I want to say,
I think I'm just,
I might be pulling rabbits out of a hat here and I don't even know there are
rabbits in the hat is a terrible metaphor,
but,
uh,
I get a more viscous sort of caramelly type experience.
Absolutely.
I'm
totally different from the Jamison that's due to the heavy corn use here,
and it's due to the new wood that's used here.
So the Jamison doesn't use the near the same amount of the charred new barrels
that the jack does.
And so it gives it that richness,
gives that viscosity.
Now what about,
um,
how would you explain?
For instance,
I went to Kentucky to visit drew Curtis,
who's a friend of mine.
At one point he runs a site called FARC,
which fark.com which is hilarious and amazing.
You should all check it out.
And we went,
we went through a lot of bourbon and whiskey and whatnot and I didn't really gel
with Bourbon until I had bullet bourbon and then have a bunch of,
you know,
kind of behind us in the,
in the cabinet a,
B,
u,
l,
e,
I t in the way that someone explained that to me was it has a higher rye content
and that's probably why you like it.
If you had to guess or two to explain that,
what would you say?
Like is it,
why did,
why was bought so much easier for me to drink?
I think it's a,
it's a little mean that compared to the Jack,
which I find somewhat showy,
you know,
it has a lot of,
the volume is turned up on just a couple of things.
Yeah.
Um,
to me the volume is turned up quite as loud with the bullet and there may be
more pieces to it.
You know,
got almost a little finer,
has a little bit more cut on the pallet.
And I don't mean bludgeoned like,
you know,
straight punch in the face of flavor.
It just,
it's almost,
um,
more live and go in a certain noise.
Subdued.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Got It.
So it's like if you're listening to music and the base is out of control and
shaking your car yup.
The rest of it might be fine,
but you can't listen to it for long.
Exactly.
God,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
The bullets tasty.
I do.
I do like the bullet quite a bit.
So let's see,
we are on the e h Taylor Rye.
All right.
What did you think?
Sorry guys.
These silences must be fascinating.
It's,
yeah,
it's,
it's very,
has a lot of bites.
So I struggled to,
Ooh,
Yup.
It comes from two things.
It has a lot of bites.
So I was still really struggling to try to separate the,
and this is the one that I said smelled more like Turpentine.
To me it's,
um,
I was struggling to sort of separate that,
that like kick in the nuts from the flavor profile.
But I just,
I was having trouble.
I was traveling trouble doing it.
It takes practice,
practice,
practice.
So the,
the bite comes from,
you have 10% more alcohol here,
then the last one you to drink.
So I'm sure you feel that.
But also the rye gives it a bite and they sort of play in the same range.
When we were talking about musical ranges,
Turpentine,
um,
can also play in the same range as the ride.
They're all high toned aromatics.
What desire,
what do you mean by that?
So when I,
when I smell,
I think about the musical range and you know,
the fat notes or the base and then there's this Meza,
which everything has,
it's kind of,
uh,
you know,
neither here nor there.
But the alto tends to be where these,
these high tone notes of,
of flowers,
of spice,
um,
something like Turpentine,
these,
it's the stuff that lives up,
up high and you know,
you can almost physically feel that in your nose when you smell.
Oh,
oh yeah,
I did 100%.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
it's pretty interesting.
And so the rye on the palate plays almost in the same vein as the alcohol that
serves to make it spicy and give it cut.
Huh?
No,
I was just wondering,
there are standardized tests for vision,
uh,
and people have eye checks up checkups.
They go to the ophthalmologist or whatever their standardized tests for hearing.
Yes.
I can't think of anytime in my life where an iPad,
my smell tested.
Yeah.
Unless he faint.
They put the salts hundred those exist though.
I mean are there standardized smelling ability measurements of any time?
Not that I know of.
Know what the hell's got.
I'll put that.
You know what,
I wouldn't endorse him even if there were,
I'm,
I'm a big believer in making this thing inclusive.
Not Exclusive.
No,
no,
no.
Understood.
But like for instance,
if you wanted to,
not exclusive in the same way,
like some people say if you have a mixed dog,
you shouldn't try to find out what the breed is because then you will impose on
that dog expectations.
And in the same way,
if you found out you had,
uh,
a low,
I'm interested in it.
Not so much to decide if I am a good or a bad smeller,
but to be able to track some type of progress.
Sure.
It goes a metric that's fair.
But just,
you know,
like if you wear glasses,
you can never fly a fighter plane.
I wouldn't want anyone to feel like they can't be a happy drinker if they,
you know,
I have a bad nose.
Right.
You feel condemned to not participate.
Fair enough.
I guess it depends on how quirky they're nerd them is when it comes to metrics
and tracking.
I have lots of foibles and a neuroses,
but fortunately I guess I can,
I can get a bad report card and just want to improve it.
Totally.
So this is that Japanese Yen,
Japan.
Exactly.
Well,
he saw she put it on there.
That means long time.
No,
see basically,
which by the way is from Chinese actually.
It's,
um,
how'd y'all put yet?
Which literally means well,
yeah,
it's like long time.
No,
see how'd y'all,
what's yen?
Uh,
which is the same gin is sites yet and see you again.
all right,
so this is the Japanese Tonkotsu.
Yup.
He's thoughtfully tasting everyone.
That is amazing.
That,
I love that.
That's very,
it's just very silky.
It's not,
there aren't any kind of rough aspects to it.
Nope.
Like I could just sit there for hours.
Me Too.
And they do.
Wow.
It's um,
I'm going to write that one down.
This is the,
what was it,
17 years?
17 year and Nika and I.
K.
A.
Yup.
Taketsuru.
Taketsuru T.
You.
Wow,
that's good stuff.
Yeah.
So it comes back to that idea of balance,
right?
And,
and use.
So like the first four you tasted or maybe bounced in different ways,
but I don't think he liked the ry quite as much.
The riot I could like on the rocks as one drank with some bros before we play
pool fine.
But I couldn't sit down and nurse that right.
For like hours of a poker guy.
He's an interesting,
and then similarly you might,
you might not take the Taketsuru Sudu and make a Manhattan with it.
Like you would the rye.
Right.
So then you add sweet vermouth.
It calms the write down.
You stir it over rocks and temperature calms the right down.
Right.
So all these,
you know,
sick where,
where's the end point for these things?
So I'm with you.
I'm probably not sipping the h Taylor know very often unless I'm around a
campfire and it's all there is.
But the Takotsubo the it is really fascinating.
Hell,
uh,
whether it's the Irish distilling process,
the characteristics of the Japanese Scotch,
they really match the sort of cultural stereotypes.
Yeah.
Well totally.
Um,
there's a,
there's a really,
I think it's a fascinating book.
There are gems in it,
even though some of it may be found very boring to people,
uh,
to shrimp up called in praise of shadows.
And it's a book on sort of architecture and aesthetics written by a Japanese
fellow whose name is escaping me right now,
I want to say like honeys Aki.
But I could be making that up and just talks about how,
for instance,
people in the West will buy objects from Japan that have a gold foil or
embroidering and put it in their homes.
But it looks gaudy.
Yup.
And the reason that was,
or the reason that's the case is that Japan and Japanese aesthetic makes use of
shadow and darkness more.
So they,
they compensated for that darkness by having a more ornamentation with things
like gold smart cause you'd be seeing it in low light settings and just the
whole,
the whole book is really interesting.
Talks about,
you know,
the,
uh,
he has very strong opinions about Gad Japanese versus Western toilets and
whatnot.
It's just,
it's,
but that type of sensibility,
uh,
you can detect even in the absence of the Scotch,
which is cool.
It applies to wine too.
Same,
same parable,
Huh?
Yeah.
Uh,
and then this and now we have the mainland mainland Edward,
our 10 year old scotch.
All right.
Now I'll,
while I taste all that you answer this,
I think that a lot of people,
myself included,
tend to assume or have a bias towards older age.
Like,
oh,
it must be better if it's older.
It's the same once the,
it's the same rule with wine.
More expensive isn't better,
older as in better.
Um,
and in some cases you can actually go really too far.
I mean,
I feel like for you that the,
the,
the Rye,
which is 10 years old is probably beyond the pleasure principle for Tim and
things age at different rates depending on where they are.
So it's cold and wet in Scotland.
Proof can actually tend to come down in the aging.
You can lose some alcohol through evaporation and um,
whereas you lose less water because it's so humid,
but it takes,
because it's cooler and wetter,
it takes more time to develop the Patina that happens with age.
Whereas if you're in a,
uh,
Rick House,
which is just an aging warehouse in Kentucky,
like even today and to summer,
it's hot,
it's really hot.
So that whole thing proceeds at a much greater pace,
much faster.
And you can,
you can blow right by the sweet spot and get to something that just becomes a,
a varnish sheet Turpin tiny extract of Oak and you've lost all the other
character in nuance,
which makes perfect sense,
right?
I mean,
because if you have that added heat,
all the metabolic processes are accelerating.
What was the name of this again?
I'm so bad at spelling anything from Scotland because there are lots of o u g h
is and so on that I actually can't make sense of.
But what was the name of that?
This is Edward Hour.
So e d r a d.
O.
U.
R tenure.
I think it'll actually Scotland's smallest distillery.
I like this a lot.
It's my favorite in Scotland.
Oh,
no kidding.
Yep.
This is done.
The mainland.
Yeah.
Really,
really nice.
And I don't,
words are failing me.
Uh,
which suppose happens a fair amount,
but particularly in this case,
how would you describe this to me?
It's,
it's pretty and rich,
which is kind of a,
again,
back to balance.
It's a hard balancing point.
It's easy to get rich.
Well,
I feel like it.
How do you stay pretty well,
I also feel like it's strong.
Like it has,
uh,
and look guys,
for those people listening,
like I get really irritated by sort of the snobbery that can come with a lot of
this,
but I'm lacking better words to use.
But if so,
yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of ridiculous stuff out there when it comes to beverages at the
high end and so on.
However,
with this,
like the way I would describe this is it's a lot stronger,
not necessarily an alcohol content,
but the,
the characteristics and the flavors are a lot stronger than Japanese.
Exactly.
But just short of like really headbutting me in the face,
like the,
uh,
the Rye,
the Rye.
Yeah.
And so this I could do for a longer period of time total.
You know,
it's kind of like 75 is perfect.
85 if you're in the sun can be too much.
And this is like a hanging out right below that threshold.
Yup.
I totally agree.
It feels like more,
I mean,
when I take this,
I actually tastes raising nets.
Oh,
interesting.
It's such a trip.
I mean,
I get the malted milkshake thing,
but also like that the chocolate over the reason and it's rich and it's yummy
and it,
where's the alcohol?
Well,
hmm.
Yeah,
I do get it.
Yeah.
I mean,
power of suggestion being what it is.
Yeah.
Um,
what about,
uh,
let's,
so this is the,
the islander,
exactly.
This is full gas on a lot of friends.
Big.
It's rich.
It's a,
the most alcoholic on the table as 54.2% alcohol.
So that's a 108.4 proof.
Not for the meek.
From Ardbeg who?
Goodall.
Yeah.
I'll put her on your chest.
Trouble with that.
I was trying to do the,
the,
what is it,
the aeration and swishing and whatnot.
I was like,
oh my God,
I could barely get the first part down.
Fuck it is put a little bit in your mouth and it just fills your whole cranium
head crazy perfume.
Yeah.
It's um,
very perfumed.
I'm very smoky.
Yeah.
Just like before,
I love sipping on these,
but just in small amounts a drink,
it's like it's a sip.
Yeah.
That would have to be like sitting reading a book someplace at your own speed
someplace cold,
cold,
snowing outside.
Sounds like an island in Ireland maybe.
Yeah,
exactly.
To Scotland are Scotland.
I'm so sorry.
I'm supposed to know punching them that your phones as we see.
Uh,
so the,
now let's,
let's talk about one other thing and then we can introduce it.
Maybe is,
is a,
a story.
So tell me this,
the story you told me about the convoy and let's use that as a segue to mezcal.
Yes,
let's do.
Um,
so I was telling you a story about a,
I have a mezcal Brian,
it's called Sombra.
Um,
I started 10 years ago actually when everybody thought I was selling Mescalin
rich,
you're going to go to jail.
I was like,
what do you mean I'm gonna go to jail?
I think,
well,
Mescalin is illegal.
It's a drug.
I was like,
no,
no.
It's not masculine.
It's Mescal,
you know,
without going through the long strokes.
Um,
10 years has taken us a long ways and we've gone from a time when everybody
thought that sits actually,
you know,
on everybody's lips.
Um,
so miss gal is really the authentic,
a Gob,
a spirit of Mexico.
Everyone talks about Tequila.
Tequila is really changed and in a lot of ways it's been bastardized over the
last,
well since 1860 when it became tequila.
Before that it too was misco.
So for me,
the idea is how you were ways,
I'm sorry to interrupt.
And in what ways does it become bastardized?
So at a certain point you could have used dozens of different types of a Gavi to
make and you can still mescal and Tequila was one of those things.
Um,
and when it went from being Vayner Dmexco to being Tequila,
they legislated for industry,
not for artistry.
So no longer could you use these,
you know,
20 some flavors and,
and Gaba is blue,
Gavi or just blue.
And they'd say,
because the best,
well,
it's not necessarily the best.
It's the best if you want something to grow big,
fast,
soft.
So it's easy to cut.
And now they carry this monoculture of,
I mean,
it's like in Cheetahs there's no DNA variability.
And so the first sibling cheetahs,
yeah.
You know how they're about to be extinct because there's,
there's low no.
Oh yeah.
Their,
their gene pool is so tiny that if like they,
everyone's afraid.
If one of them catches the flu,
they're all going to die.
No variability.
None whatsoever.
So the same thing's happened in Tequila with Bluecava and that.
So that's why they have these blights that take out all these plants as a
production.
Yeah.
It's a huge time.
Alright.
And so in addition to the plant,
it was the processing methods have changed and you,
you are so far from what was originally produced and Tequila,
um,
to get to what they're making today that hey,
I still drink this stuff,
but um,
but it's not,
if you drink tequila,
what do you drink?
It's kind of like the DOS Equis guy.
I don't drink it took you a long time,
but when I do,
I drink,
I drink a lot of [inaudible] leg was I think the physical yet they was okay.
They do a great job I think to get this seven linguals Lagos,
Lagos?
Yup.
L E.
G.
U.
S.
Um,
I like the guys that's Keela Oto.
Actually,
I don't know the guys to get hit.
We'll try like their tequila a lot.
Um,
and then we make one called us thrall,
like astral.
Yeah.
Which is really a deliberate throwback to what was it like before 1860 when they
legislated for,
got it.
Basically if I could production.
Um,
so for me,
mescal is,
it's the,
it's the real thing.
You know,
what it embodies that intellectual value we've been talking about and it
embodies plot,
a process in place and people on geology and the geography and history and
cuisine.
It's all in there.
So that's,
that's interesting to me.
And so we've been down there doing this stuff,
but it's definitely what is miss golf with.
So for people who haven't had it,
so think of it as Tequila from the rest of Mexico,
but for sure it's going to be more full flavored.
So much like this last Scott,
you had that,
um,
where they use peat in the process that gives it that sense.
Key quality.
Yeah.
It has the very smoky in characteristic.
So if we just take a step back and you think,
okay,
well what is,
if
mezcal is made from Gavi,
what's it Gavi?
Gavi has starch and you need yeast to eat sugar,
to make alcohol use.
Don't eat starch.
So you may,
well,
you turn starch into a sugar is with heat and today,
um,
it's done with steam or even with enzymes and some strange cases,
cases I try to avoid personally,
but,
um,
traditionally it's done with fire.
And so in my scalp production,
you actually dig a hole in the ground.
You build a fire,
you put rocks over that fire,
and then you put the Gavi hearts in there and you roast them for two days,
buried in the ground in that that heat converts the starch to sugar.
It also much like this last scotch,
it imbues it with a smoky flavor.
And so that's why miss call has that smokey equality.
And so think of it like,
you know,
the original Tequila,
a smoke and a that's based in Mexico,
that's based in Wahaca,
Wahaca,
Mexico.
So almost the very most of them is for a molar,
also famous from Olin,
great food,
amazing people,
amazing traditions.
Um,
and little unpredictable or,
yeah,
it's definitely unpredictable.
Um,
you can,
you know,
there's so much beauty and so many wonderful things and you definitely have to
watch your step.
So what,
what happened with the convoy?
So what happened?
The coffee where there was some,
some friends and business associates.
And um,
after being out at our Polanque K or two cars pulled back on,
you know,
says 17 pulling keys where you distill and after driving from the distillery and
the mountains,
17 kilometers down a dirt road back to the main highway,
which is the Pan American,
we turned onto the Pan American highway and two trucks of state police soldiers
pulled in front of our two cars and start slowing down.
And the guy was driving the car in front of us,
didn't understand the clues,
which is we were also supposed to slow down and stop.
[inaudible]
yeah,
he was,
yeah.
Lot.
We'll Hawkin.
Yeah.
Yup.
He's the son of the guy that was driving our car.
Got It.
Um,
and just didn't want to know the clues didn't pick up on the hint,
which was a little scary cause you know,
and you know,
in a half a breath you had two trucks of soldiers with their rifles pointed at
the car.
And My,
my,
uh,
the guy that works for us down there,
he's an amazing guy.
He's been there forever.
He knows the clothes and he's like,
grabbing the kid,
stop the car,
stop the car.
And I would imagine,
I mean the averting faster and they're stopping the car.
I would imagine,
I mean,
I've had this experience in Panama,
I've had at many other places to extract potentially extract like a more like a
little,
have a nice day.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Have a nice day.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I don't think I've actually been on that road without having been stopped and
had the car empty that at one point or another.
Um,
you know,
I'm told from our local friends that it's always better when we're in the car.
You know,
I wouldn't obviously know the converse situation.
Um,
but you know,
all in all,
everybody is okay and that's all that matters.
I had a scary experience and uh,
well scary because I'm not accustomed to this happening elsewhere in the United
States.
Been Panama where I was driving out
from Panama City to,
I want to say book it there or I was actually driving to an,
to the coast to go to the [inaudible] marine reserve,
which is amazing.
And uh,
I got stopped a million times because he's just like obvious white dude in a
pickup truck driving.
And uh,
the tip I got before arriving in Panama,
I was getting an international drivers license because when they pull you over,
they're going to ask you for your passport and if you handed over,
you don't get it back.
Now you won't get it back until you do everything that they ask you to do.
Yup.
But if you have an international drivers license and you say you don't have a
passport,
and then they say,
well we were supposed to find you but then you have to go to trial and this
place and the other and then they protocol the dance is,
is there any way I could pay my fine now,
but the price is going to be 10 20 a hundred acts if they've your passport as
opposed to the international driver's license.
Yup.
Same thing happens in France all the time in France.
Oh,
the joke used to be with myself and my friends and we were doing a lot of wine
work.
There is that,
you know,
don't let Richard drive right off the plane.
I said at some point,
first day getting pulled over.
Same Story.
Give me your passport.
Of course.
I'm never giving them my passport.
You can have my driver's license.
Plenty of those.
But um,
same,
same story.
Oh yeah.
Pay This fine.
Right on the side of the road.
It's so wild.
Yeah.
It happens more places than not,
I would say for sure.
Brazil's the scariest,
but that's another podcast.
Yeah.
Uh,
you can see what is it?
Throughput the Elitch,
the,
uh,
elite squad or elite team.
There's a movie.
You could watch that and then you'll know what I'm talking about.
Now the second one is pretty good as well.
Uh,
so the,
uh,
let me,
let me ask you a couple of rapid fire questions as I nursed this Tonkotsu to do
it.
Uh,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind and why?
My folks,
both of them equally,
my parents,
why they were able to come from a place that's,
I mean I,
I consider myself successful,
but when I look at what they did,
I think of their road is having been so much harder,
so much harder.
I'm super impressed.
So his,
his success then in the overcoming of obstacles,
it's finding your way to happiness and that's what it is.
And,
and that doesn't have to be associated with anything material or not.
And for them it was just changing the surroundings and finding a way out.
You know,
there was no helping hand.
You gotta you gotta do it yourself when do you,
so if you had to pick someone besides your parents,
someone beside my parents.
Oh,
I,
you and I share lots of friends,
many of whom are successful and it's really anyone that makes their own way.
Um,
so our buddy,
I mean,
yeah.
Soka he's been on the podcast,
extremely safe to say he's cut his own way.
He's cut his own way.
Um,
I mean,
Obama's cut his own way,
you know,
so many people.
Just to be clear to folks that is not a mutual friend or at least,
yeah,
I don't know him on a first name basis,
but you know what I mean.
It's someone that maybe against odds has,
has figured out how to do what they love do and
that's pretty cool.
When do you lose track of time?
I lose track of time on airplanes or I spend a lot of time and I actually,
Tim,
I really tried to take that time for myself.
I,
I like getting on the airplane and there are times like this morning when,
when I flew here I was like,
you know what?
I'm going to fly backs.
Afternoon,
I have to work.
But 99% of the time when I got in the plane,
that's Richard Time and I shut it off and I get in a book and what used to be
long flights are over in a minute and we're even just think or anything.
But that's,
that's where I actually lose track of time.
How many days a year do you fly?
I am,
I sleep in a hotel more than 300 nights a year.
Wow.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll do 117 hundred and 80,000 miles is here.
What book are you currently reading?
Um,
it's the,
um,
El,
please don't be mad when I slightly title wrong.
Mus the intersection option.
Yeah.
I haven't read over there in the corner.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Elle Luna.
Check it out guys.
I actually buy,
actually bought 2000 plus copies of that to mail out with this quarter quarterly
mailing that I sent out to people.
That's amazing.
That's a really,
really excellent book.
What book will,
so speaking of gifting,
what book do you gift have you gifted most often to other people?
For sure.
It's my favorite book ever.
It's called a fan's notes,
a fan's notes,
a fan's notes by Fred Exley.
What does that,
um,
I don't know.
It was probably 50 years on since it was written.
And Fred's amazing,
super smart for,
for me,
there's,
this is like first,
second and third place in terms of best book.
Oh Wow.
That's a strong,
it's a brilliant guy who keeps messing up his life over and over again.
Is this autobiographical?
He says patient.
He says that certain events may resemble his own life.
Okay.
That's considered a novel.
Yes,
it is.
Got It.
Okay.
Yeah.
And it's,
um,
it's painful and I'm,
I'm not,
I don't see sad movies.
I don't read overtly sad things.
Um,
but this is,
it's neither of those things,
but man,
it's such a lesson.
It's really,
really special.
What,
what are,
and it's funny and it's literary and it's,
it's nuts.
What is one of the,
what do you get from it when you,
when you read it?
So I take it you've read it more than once.
I'm probably on it.
It's actually about a third through again,
it's next to next to my bed and I'm probably on my 12th or 13th reading.
What do you get from it?
Resolve.
Oh,
that's good.
Yeah,
it's huge.
That's the everything.
I mean,
I'd be a liar if I didn't say I'm not totally motivated by many factors,
including a fear of failure.
It's,
I,
I would like to say that that's not true,
but I'm supremely motivated by it.
What is failure in your mind?
And it could be something very specific.
I mean like whether it's related to business or whatever,
but like in your mind right now,
what is the fear?
What is the failure that you're afraid of not achieving the things I want to
achieve?
Like,
well,
continuing to work for myself,
which is great.
That's huge.
I mean time is everything.
I mean there's,
there's nothing in my mind besides time and having your opportunity to decide
how to spend it.
That's because it's going to be over and only what you want to believe.
I believe that we get one swing and that's it.
I want to make it great and not having the occasion to decide what I do not have
any occasion to express myself in whatever way.
I feel like that's failure.
Yeah.
It's a horrifying thought.
Like I'd be physically ill thinking about it.
If you,
I think you're a spectacularly good teacher.
Uh,
if you were teaching a ninth grade class,
you could teach anything you wanted.
Yep.
What would the class be?
Love Yourself.
Yeah.
You've got to love yourself before you love others.
And without it,
nothing productive is going to happen when we can all bang our heads on the
wall.
But unless you really,
really come from place of like,
this is who I am,
this is what I,
I have,
which is like a mind trapped in a physical being trapped in a,
in a meat cube.
Yeah.
Trapped in a meat cube.
Like you have to like acknowledge that and then make the most of it.
I mean really appreciate yourself.
And especially in ninth grade,
that was like,
I mean my daughter actually just entered 10th grade,
but that's like such a tough time on kids.
I remember I won a tough time I had in you,
it's very easy to lose your bearings.
Like are they doing it right?
Are they doing it right?
Am I doing it wrong?
Like all that,
just like,
you know,
love yourself.
I always thought I was going to be a night like a teacher and specifically want
teach ninth grade because that's,
that's the uh,
so the fork and so many paths,
you know what I mean?
Total.
What,
so how would you help someone cultivate loving themselves?
It's,
I'll be honest,
I have trouble with that.
I beat the shit out of myself all the time.
Yeah.
I think I'm helping some cultivate that.
I think,
well,
it's probably what I'm starting to feel,
but it's stuck it sooner.
Yeah,
it's good.
I would say it probably comes with context again.
You know,
I mean,
we're always like,
grass is always greener.
Well why don't you taste that grass,
right?
And see what it is and see what it actually feels like.
Try It on,
tasted it,
put your toes in it.
And if you,
if there's a way to,
again,
give people context of other things.
We've done it with our daughter by,
with travel.
Um,
you know,
we just got back from the Galapagos islands two weeks ago by far the best place
I've ever been in the Galapagos themselves are really amazing.
And then you spent some time in why Akil and that's a real story of have and
have nots.
And it's an amazing thing.
But know,
just as one example of,
you know,
what is it like to,
to live these other lives and everybody struggles,
but the happiest people are,
that's the real wealth is being happy.
And if you can show people,
give examples of people that are happy,
you know,
regardless of their material circumstances,
I think that's,
that's a way to share with kids that it's worth loving yourself and making the
most of it.
You know,
when you look at,
uh,
your financially successful friends,
both of us know a
lot of people that have achieved extraordinary levels of financial success.
And we'll,
we'll exclude Chris from this conversation because I don't want anyone to think
that we're referring to him.
I think Chris is a,
uh,
a case study.
I'm very fascinated by him because he's,
he's crafted an incredible life for himself.
Absolutely.
But of those financially successful people who are
unhappy,
Yup.
Generally unhappy.
What do you think they have in common?
What did the,
what are the,
why are they unhappy?
Misplace goals.
Yeah.
And you know,
chasing,
chasing the financial award purely for the financial award is not the right way
to do it in my esteem.
You know,
that first chef that gave me that first wine job,
he was great.
We were,
we were overlooked for a couple things in the press and I'm,
you know,
I'm new in this,
this world food wine world and he's like,
look,
Richard,
do you know,
if you work for the awards,
you know,
you don't,
you don't do good work,
but if you do good work,
the awards will come.
And they might not even be the specific press things.
But I think that that people that do have that fantastic wealth and are unhappy,
um,
okay.
You know,
they,
maybe they worked for the wrong thing.
Maybe,
you know,
barring things like traumatic loss of a loved one or something like that.
You know,
all that aside,
maybe they don't love themselves.
Maybe they don't know how to share.
Sharing is a big deal.
Like,
you know,
or maybe you just maybe just believing the wrong thing,
asking for help is a big deal too.
Yeah,
it is a big deal.
It's a huge deal.
There's a,
there's a book by Amanda Palmer has also been on the podcast partially because I
read her book,
the art of asking,
yeah.
Incredible musician,
but just fucking ask for help already.
You know what you want.
I,
because I grew up as such a bookworm,
I constantly try to revert to like pro and con lists and writing and research to
solve problems and like nine times out of 10,
especially after I read that book,
I was like,
Jesus Christ Ferris.
Like you could've just called this friend for that.
Yeah.
This friend for that.
And they would have been happy to help.
Yeah,
totally.
Another thing I think is a little bit out of left field,
but I think that some of those people,
people forget you'd have meat box he said were contained and you got to take
care of that thing.
Yeah.
You see so many people that are unhappy because they doubt.
You know,
and,
and I,
I live in this weird place.
Like I make people happy by sharing booze,
knowledge and accessibility with them too much.
There is such thing as too much of a good thing and that,
you know,
and so you see a lot of that too.
I mean you are,
you know,
a trafficker of,
of goodness but also vices for a lot of hundred percent.
Right.
I struggle with that actually.
Well,
no,
no.
And I'm not saying that in an accusatory fashion cause I've got an,
I mean I have an entire closet full of booze behind us.
Yeah.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
my question for you,
I mean,
you're in very good shape.
You travel 300 days of the year or more.
Yup.
What are some of the keys?
What do you choose your hotels wisely as in make sure that the gym is real.
In fact,
the best hotels don't have a gym at all,
but they have a relationship with a real gym,
you know,
across the street or down the block or something that,
that actually probably guides my hotel choice tend to one to any other factor.
How do you determine that?
Well,
you know,
that's big thing.
Part of it's experience,
right?
So like I love to stay at the standard East village in Manhattan,
not the high line,
but east village because they don't have a gym,
but they have a relationship with the New York health club right across his
drinking.
I said he just kind of like,
you dig around,
you can find that stuff.
But,
um,
I mean,
physical fitness is,
it's Paramount's me.
I know that I think better when I'm healthy.
Oh yeah.
I'm a nicer guy when I've exercised and actually I actually,
I really try to peak.
So if I'm at home,
I have the most amazing trainer,
Aaron Carson and Boulder.
She's awesome.
And we've figured out the schedule,
so let's do a real,
um,
you know,
build over seven or if I'm the home for even 10 days,
which is rare,
even four days,
like let's make it hard,
hard,
and then I need a rest day when I have to get on the lane.
Travel that smartly.
Yeah.
So you really try to fit him in there.
What,
uh,
what is your week?
Let's just say you're traveling for a month at a time.
Yep.
What is your week of exercise look like?
Minimum seven,
her apartment,
five out of seven days,
minimum of five.
And you know,
sometimes that might be tried to do mornings,
mornings.
What time as you know what I have to caffeinate I would be whole hire fire.
Didn't say I'm uh,
I'm fully addicted to caffeine for it from tea to coffee,
but I'll take it however I can get it.
A type of tea we drink.
A lot of people belong,
a lot of poo air.
Um,
those are the two that matter a lot.
I have a friend,
he,
I would have considered myself like a coffee geek.
Xtrordinair um,
everything dialed in and the Scales and the,
you know,
the temperature,
everything would be like perfect.
Um,
and then I met this guy,
Sebastian,
who taught me all about tea and I had tried so hard,
like,
you know,
I read,
read something like,
Oh man,
I should really know about tea.
Like it appeals to my wine minder.
Sure.
And I could never do it.
And I met Sebastian.
He just ruined me.
And it's a ruined you in a good way.
I want a good way.
So it's all about in pursuit of tea now.
It's cool.
Yeah,
it's the best.
Yeah.
So caffeine and then try to exercise right away.
And certainly before you get into the email or your phone or any of that stuff,
what time do you wake up when you're on the road?
Or do you try to wake up?
I try to get a minimum of eight hours.
So the time is a moving target,
especially when,
you know,
I've been in five times zones in the last seven.
You have to socialize at night with.
It's huge.
No.
When you,
there's the travel to talk to retailers and distributors,
is that primarily like what accounts for the bulk of the travel?
Um,
you know,
it's,
I can't,
it's a lot of two things.
Making and selling,
right?
So the making part is easy.
It's easy to,
I mean,
for me,
dream something up and you go and you create it,
you know,
and it's a physical thing and you have something,
it's done.
Um,
but that takes work.
I mean,
I make things,
um,
on three continents today,
which continent?
Uh,
Australia,
um,
wine.
Yeah.
We,
so we make wine Australia.
What's it gone?
It's a called sue set,
which is s u.
C.
E.
T.
First one comes out next month actually.
Oh,
that's exciting.
So let's put,
let's put a date on that because people will listen to this for months.
Okay.
So that's going to be Tobar of 2015.
Yeah.
Cool.
And Suzette means to suckle and old French since it's a,
yeah,
it's a cool,
exactly.
You let your mind run wild with that.
I wasn't going to say it.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the white wine will be called Nisha phone and I'll let you look that up.
Um,
have you smell it?
I'll let everybody will look at I c.
H.
O.
N.
Yeah,
you guys can put that together.
We make some rosé under my essential,
uh,
brand in the south of France.
And of course it makes number mescaline.
Wahaca um,
so what I meaning shadow some remaining shadow.
How did you choose that name?
Uh,
two ways.
First of all,
I mean,
I think mescal is a little,
even still a little forbidden,
a little dangerous.
And I believe everybody has a dark side.
I'm certain of it.
I know I do.
Um,
and the second is maybe a little bit more,
um,
historically referential of Mescal,
very much in the shadow of Tequila.
Ah,
I like that.
Yeah.
I have a friend who's done a lot of work with,
uh,
shall we say plant medicine,
psychedelics and awesome.
And oddly enough,
he,
that's true,
right?
The little people and Mushrooms,
sacred mushrooms have been used for Millennia and Mexico of course.
Uh,
and he did not spend time in Mexico,
but for whatever reason,
he drank all sorts of different alcoholic beverages before this work.
And now for whatever reason,
he can only drink miss gow.
Yeah,
no,
I believe that.
I don't know why,
but that's,
it's the only beverage that he can consume.
Uh,
he does it very irregularly,
but when it comes to alcohol,
Miss Gallon's,
all he can consume.
That's amazing.
Out of nowhere.
Yeah.
Wow.
Crazy.
Really Weird.
Or It's good for Ya.
Yeah,
apparently.
So a and M,
well,
the other half of that travel question,
why so much is the selling piece,
so,
right.
So if you the listener one to buy a bottle of Sombra,
the first thing I had to do was important to America,
then you have to sell it thanks to um,
you know,
the repeal of prohibition and all the laws that followed that I have to sell it
to distributor.
So then we have to sell it to a retailer and then the retailer has to sell to
you.
So there all these things.
So I can't just assume that you'd make the first sale and then it ends up on
your shelf.
We'll find somewhere like for those people listening,
thankfully everywhere,
10 years later,
all across America,
everywhere,
everywhere.
So like if I went to,
I'm just making one up here,
what does it KNL here?
Am I making absolutely k and l wine there or he's not wine the candle.
I Dunno if Kaino has it,
but we're certainly all over San Francisco.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well you guys can search for it.
So,
uh,
what is the hundred dollars or less purchase that comes to mind that has had the
biggest impact on life?
That's
interesting.
Um,
I'm not a material guy.
And having that set of like next who's got something free,
something what?
It could be something free.
Can it be donation?
Can it be a donation?
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean we try to support small things in many ways all the time.
So my daughter and I just,
um,
gave to donors choose and Oh yes,
she's amazing.
Dollar shoes is amazing.
I'm on their advisory board.
Oh,
that's so cool.
I've been doing stuff donor shoes for like seven years.
Yeah.
So to have the occasion to like sit with her and figure out like,
hey,
we want to give it to this class near our community.
Here's why mean it's enriching because you get to enrich that experience and
donors choose.
But it's enriching for my daughter and I to have that discussion and it
facilitates so much more,
you know,
and father daughter time and her education and that's,
that's meaningful.
Totally.
Yeah.
I um,
my parents used to help me.
I want to see it was a UNICEF,
but I could be giving that completely wrong.
I think I am.
But determining what to donate to someone in a third world country,
whether it be like a number of chickens or a goat or a this or that.
And the,
the the conversation,
uh,
and walking your kid through,
helping them walk themselves through the decision is a fascinating,
it's very valuable.
Yeah.
Do you have favorite movie or documentary?
Several.
Um,
you,
it's funny also on the topic of the kid.
Uh,
we watched the breakfast club last night.
Oh Wow.
First blast from the past.
Yeah.
So she's just started high,
uh,
sophomore year in high school and new school.
And I was like,
this is,
I remember this being so formative 30 years ago for me and we watched it and
just,
you know,
shooting tears and laughter and the whole thing.
But there's so many great movies like that.
I wouldn't say that's my favorite,
but for sure that,
that's the most recent my mind.
Um,
I love the movie.
Baraka is actually a good one.
Yeah.
Very visual.
And it really reminds me of,
of a lot of things.
We one B a r a.
K.
A.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Baraka for me is meaningful because it talks about how amazing our planet is,
how fragile our planet is.
It reminds me of the geologic timescale.
This is like a profoundly important thing to me at the geologic timescale.
When you look at how long it's taken,
everything and how,
I mean,
what's San Francisco gonna look like in several hundred years and what we're all
going to be long gone.
In fact,
humanity might be gone.
Who knows?
Who knows what will happen,
but that we're just this tiny little blip in,
in time,
like we matter,
not at all.
And so just reminds me to party.
Have a great time here.
You're barely here.
Get after it and crush your life.
It's awesome.
Don't take everything so seriously.
Totally.
Yeah,
totally.
That's,
that's it.
Um,
with your workouts,
if you could only choose three exercises or types of exercise for your workouts,
what would you choose?
Burpees.
Burpees?
Yup.
Um,
squats
and intervals.
What type?
Short intervals.
The 40 seconds on,
20 seconds off running.
Got It.
Yeah,
that's a good combo.
You're ready for the military?
Uh,
Tim,
I used to run a lot.
Um,
the longest I ever ran it once was 82 and a half miles.
That's fucking long.
Well,
the race was a hundred,
so that was a problem.
82 and a half miles is no joke.
Yeah.
Any.
So can you just like fuck off at any given moment and just like run 20 miles?
Um,
I think I can probably get 20 miles done.
I don't know if I could run them and that and I quit.
So after that summer,
after the [inaudible] 82 and a half,
yeah,
I,
you know,
I started running in the year 2000 when I moved to Colorado and it was great.
I loved it and I started competing and then,
you know,
as a citizen did pretty well,
um,
by no means a professional,
but I really liked it and it was a way to clear my head and they say about
runners either running from something or to something and there is for sure an
element of that to my running also.
Which one was,
which one was a real for both.
I can name both pieces.
Um,
so,
but I found,
okay,
let's go farther,
let's go farther.
And then it was,
um,
you know,
I'll trail marathons and then ha,
50 mile races and there and that was great.
And then you cross that threshold and,
and it becomes really catabolic.
Yeah.
And I was almost 30 pounds lighter than I am now.
And you're not a huge guy.
I mean you're not thin,
but you're not like a huge totally,
you don't have 30 pounds to spare.
No.
And then,
but you know,
it's about,
you know,
strength to weight ratio and how quickly you're going to get over that mountain
and then over the next mountain,
the next mountain.
And I wanted to get stronger and as things start to break,
but as you would like get strong in the gym and then you go start renting again
and your body just eats itself,
then it all goes away and you're like,
oh wow.
And then with that comes so much inflammation and I'm a big believer,
at least for me,
it's just not him.
I actually believe for people,
it's not good to run that long a distance sound.
But so feel free not to answer,
but what were you running from and running to?
Oh,
you know what,
I am,
um,
I think probably not that dissimilar to you.
I'm also very hard on myself and you know,
when I do something I want to do it very,
very well.
And I think everything was really working very,
very well for me except for my marriage.
And it wasn't working well at all.
In fact,
that was was brutal.
Um,
and I was running to a place of candor where,
again,
part of being hard on yourself as being honest with yourself and I,
I treasure candor and the occasion to sit just live in it.
Right.
So I'm running to that place where I was honest about all of it and you know,
where I was wasn't that place.
But yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not particularly good at intimate relationships.
Yeah.
I don't think I'm the worst [inaudible] abusive.
I'm not,
you know,
total bastard,
but I,
uh,
I shut off a lot.
And intimate relationships.
Yup.
It's like,
I don't like the uncontrollable,
unpredictable nature of a lot of it.
I feel you completely,
you know what I mean?
Because you're the guy,
you're the guy who has like the seven foot stack of notes on wine.
Yeah.
I that you win the game,
right?
I mean,
so to speak.
Yeah.
We're used to and it's like we're sitting for those people who aren't here,
which is everyone.
Uh,
we're right next to a bookshelf and I have an entire shelf of notebooks.
Yeah.
Right.
And it's like,
that's how I can predict the trajectory of exactly on the blank.
Yup.
But with a relationship,
oh wait,
there's another person with their own ideas and feelings and concepts and
preconceptions just like me.
Free radical.
My dog just stretched and kicked the crate door open and,
but is not moving.
It's hilarious.
She's still beautifully asleep.
Completely asleep.
Yeah.
Um,
if you could give your,
let's see,
when you were 25,
where were you
when I was 25?
I had just finished my graduate thesis and was about to take that first cooking
job in Montana.
What advice would you have given yourself at 25?
Don't be so fucking shy.
Yeah,
that's what you were shy.
Oh Dude,
I even really until recently,
I can still think of instances like within the last 24 months were like,
man,
Richard,
I wish you had been more forward.
I wish you'd,
you talked about,
I wish you would ask for x instead of being so subtle and implying it.
And I try to go for that subtle elegant thing,
which sounds really nice.
I think part of that is actually being shy and I am,
you know,
ferociously competitive with myself.
But sometimes the clues that you put outwardly are too subtle to be heard or
someone's just talking louder than you.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and that's,
that's actually more and more the case I think.
So,
um,
I would have told myself to then much more forward.
And what about at 30?
So let's,
let's put a tire mark on that.
Where were you at 30,
30?
Um,
my daughter had been born four months prior.
I had the best wine job in the world.
Um,
I was getting fit living in Aspen,
learning a ton,
um,
very,
very focused on this master.
So my exam.
Um,
and that
would I do there,
I would probably party a little less,
which I,
you know,
I keep coming back to this thing of balance.
And so yeah,
you're an aspen and the party like a rock star,
it's party time.
Wow.
What that means for me is I also want to be competitive and all these other
levels so you have to balance it with exercising like an Olympian.
And I did that and so everything was very,
very full and it was great.
You know,
the exercise was crazy,
the party was crazy,
the sleep wasn't much.
Family Time was interesting and wonderful on so many levels,
um,
and not on others.
And then you're working and you're studying for this exam.
Right.
And so if,
um,
I don't believe in regret.
I do not believe in regret.
And so I don't want this to come across as that.
But if I had that piece to Redo,
I would dial back some of the party.
Not all of it.
I still love,
I still party.
I love it.
But,
um,
but I would take some of that back and then reallocate that time elsewhere.
Where would you allocate it?
I probably would have started my first business sooner than later.
It wasn't that far afterwards.
Yeah.
I passed the master som examine and started my first wine company the next day.
What are your first company do?
Um,
so it was called Betson shoal and I founded it with a,
an amazing guy,
Dennis Shul.
Uh,
he's,
he's really,
really a special s c h o l l s c h o.
L.
And Dennis.
Um,
I mean that's is mainly for a lot of reasons,
uh,
that you guys can look up and you should,
he's,
he's really,
he's really very,
very,
very driven also.
And we started making wine in Australia,
then we added France,
then we had a Napa valley than we co founded.
Another company called Scarpetta making wine in Italy.
And in 2009 we sold all of it.
Scarp passes who an investor group and bets and shoal to a small public company.
That was a great day.
Um,
but yeah,
you know,
it comes back to that time function.
I'm always thinking about can,
I don't want to beat myself up over something where I see an inefficiency in my
past.
But I,
you know,
if you have it to do over,
I would try to get rid of those inefficiencies.
What do you think are things that
yeah,
many people do automatically or,
okay,
well I'll leave it at that.
What are things that a lot of people do automatically or assume they have to do
that they should question.
Go to college.
Totally.
Shit.
Like,
I went to,
to college and I learned,
I mean,
we went to Occidental,
I made the Dean's list and not the good Dean's list.
I Made Dean can hours blacklist.
So what did you do to earn a place on the blacklist?
Oh,
a bunch of D's and F's and I partied.
I was just,
I mean it was in la as long ways from the beach,
but you know,
like take a kid from the desert and stick him in the city and he loves the
ocean.
I grew up on,
you know,
also in the ocean almost every weekend in Mexico with my family.
Um,
so I spent,
you know,
five days a week riding waves and not in class.
Um,
so Emma was,
that was fantastic.
I wouldn't take that back.
Um,
I learned a ton and I learned about myself.
It wasn't so much like,
you know,
I don't know a whole lot about Macbeth and I don't care and I don't feel bad
about it,
but I learned a lot about Richard Bets and that was really,
really meaningful.
I don't think I needed to go to,
you know,
a liberal arts school and spend as much money as they did,
which was all alone,
you know,
so on and so forth.
He paid it back and deal with it.
But I don't think that that was necessarily the only path to achieve that.
Whatever level of self awareness was achieved by spending that time there.
If you hadn't gone to college,
how do you think your trajectory would have been different?
I think,
you know,
I look on the bright side.
I'm hopeful that it would,
yeah.
B,
those,
um,
be more abbreviated.
So those inefficiencies and time,
I think that some of those would have gone away.
Uh,
you know,
probably would have been useful to go volunteer somewhere and just work,
um,
you know,
for,
for a good cause.
Yeah.
And come back and you develop that self awareness.
You'd be thankful for so much.
Um,
eh would have avoided some of those distractions.
Although,
I don't know Tim,
like,
I don't know if if the need to like hit the wall is genetic or not.
Like I definitely had a need to hit the wall and,
you know,
hit it hard,
hit the wall and was,
um,
yeah,
just find the guardrails,
be it with substances,
with grades,
with right.
Significant others with just a push of deliberates with physical things or you
could have died,
you know?
Yeah.
Um,
so,
okay.
Those finding that,
finding those guard rails is important,
however you find them.
What a
dean and a fancy school
yeah.
Facilitated a whole lot more fucking off.
Yeah.
It was,
Scott,
it sounds sort of care and treatment is strange,
but you're in this isolated bubble.
Yeah.
You're facing the real world.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Until you get out and you face your loans,
but you're really not facing the world.
Worald so I don't think that was super productive.
What's
would you put on a billboard if you could have a billboard anywhere?
Oh,
it average highs.
My ninth grade class.
Love Yourself.
Yeah,
there's a book that helped me quite a bit with that.
I called love yourself like your life depends on it.
It's got a very scary congress.
Uh,
yeah,
I was this guy with a gun against his head with like a heart.
It's a bike.
Come all Ravi Khan,
who is the brother.
He has the best hair in the world.
Also.
You should look up Google images.
Come over.
I've gotten had,
I wish I had his hair.
Uh,
but his brother was also interviewed on this podcast novel.
Um,
any other,
well first of all,
I want to Segue to,
uh,
obviously the book book
that is right here in front of me,
the central scratch and sniff guide to becoming a node.
All
whiskey with an e w,
h,
I.
S.
K,
e y given us country of publishing in this case.
Yeah,
exactly.
And the,
the what,
what are people gonna find in this book?
You know,
your booze before you choose.
Exactly.
You're going to find democracy is essentially it.
I think,
I think the role of the critic has never been less important.
I really believe that,
you know,
it's one thing to curate something,
but it's another thing to prescribe something.
And I'm really interested in helping people enjoy their lives.
We don't do it with stuffed shirts now.
Ascots no talking down to people,
no fancy language,
none of that.
None of that matters.
And it's certainly not inclusive.
All those things do serve to intimidate and make it exclusive.
So much like the wine book,
um,
my cocreators crystal English Sacca and Wendy McNaughton and I have tried to
apply a methodology to knock whiskey off the pedestal and say,
look,
this is it.
It's not that hard.
This is what goes in it.
This is what makes it taste the way it does.
And then decide which pieces you like and put those back together to find the
drink that's going to make you smile.
And that's,
that's the key.
You have some beauty.
I mean the format is beautiful.
I mean the layout.
Yeah,
you guys are a hell of a team.
I mean,
the crystal obviously is amazing.
Uh,
Wendy,
just incredible artists.
And uh,
for instance,
there's,
there's a a two page spread here.
It's uh,
it's Richard naked laid out on a bear hug.
No,
I'm kidding.
It's true language of the label,
uh,
in the United States and everywhere else.
And it's this bottle split in half and it allows you,
it helps,
it shows you in,
in a very graphic way or very visual way how to make sense of labels.
And then you have,
I haven't explored this yet,
but I'm excited to the map to your whiskey desires.
Exactly.
So can you explain this,
this,
that.
So once he's looked like an astrological chart,
but it's not exactly.
Essentially the book is,
it's 20 pages,
10 spreads,
um,
hardcore hard cardboard pages.
So it's that kid's book feel except for adults obviously.
And when you scratch and sniff your way through it,
you understand,
okay,
this is what the different grains smell like next.
This is what the different wood components smell like.
Finally,
this is what place smells like this is what the place where the whiskey is made
and how it's aged in parts to the different whiskeys.
So you've scratched and sniffed your way through this thing and now you put them
back together.
So you start in the middle and the first question is,
you know,
what do you do?
You want it spicy?
Okay,
well I'm guessing you probably don't because you didn't go for this Rye,
right?
Yup.
But you do like the malty thing,
right?
So,
so you were an old chick science.
So then I ended up heading outward.
This looks like a um,
a series of concentric circles.
It's kind of like a choose your own adventure map to finding your ideal group
total of whiskey.
Exactly.
And as you travel from question to question from inside to outside,
then you end up with your,
your selection of whiskey to start with.
And what's really cool,
I didn't notice until right now is,
and they,
they traverse a spectrum from mixed slash rocks to sip to sip slow.
He's like this last guy that we had,
we'd be in the sips low category low.
Exactly.
So cool.
Yeah.
So,
so cool.
We'll do this is,
this is fantastic.
I everybody's check this out.
I have given away the scratch and sniff guide that Richard and his,
uh,
his cocreators put together for wine many,
many times.
And uh,
I'm very excited about this because as insecure as I was around wine,
I could bullshit my way through it,
but I could never bullshit my way through whiskey.
And this actually gives you more than bullshit.
It gives you a very solid fundamental understanding,
not only for yourself but that you can explain to other people.
So you should definitely check that out.
Richard Bets,
B e t t.
S where can people find you on the interwebs and so on at Yo bets every old
beds.
Yeah.
Yo Bets.
Why Ovi tts and that's true of everything.
Facebook,
Twitter,
Instagram,
like Gmail.
So people can,
people can holler at you and say hello in Twitter.
Yep.
Yo Bets.
Why obts if there's any,
is there any ask,
recommendation suggestion that you have for the people listening that is not
related to the book?
I love that.
Um,
well first of all,
I'm psyched you're listening.
That's,
that's a really big deal.
My,
you know,
I mean I,
I can only speak from personal experience and that's Ah,
to be candid,
that's been the biggest
touch point is that you see,
I'm still struggling with it.
It's the biggest thing that I've,
I've really worked on over the last decade.
I mean,
my whole life being candid,
meaning being direct and with be with each other,
with yourself,
that's really where it starts.
You sure love yourself to love others,
but be candid with yourself.
Then you can be candid with others.
But like,
you know,
I don't want,
obviously we're all getting older.
I live in a business of excess and I want to get old gracefully so I can't lie
to myself and say,
Oh,
you're in good shape.
Or Ah,
you did push ups yesterday,
whatever,
you know,
like,
be honest with yourself.
Like,
look dude,
get up and do them.
You know,
or it matters.
You have to,
um,
or hey look,
you know,
maybe you're not being as good a partner as you can be to your partners.
Like,
you know,
wake up and think about how to be a great partner.
Um,
which generally means,
you know,
what's the mission of the partnership,
um,
and,
and do that or I need,
you know,
there are a million examples in all of our lives if we look around like,
and it's a matter of like,
what can we do better?
That's it.
What can you do better?
Be Candid.
Yeah.
With yourself and others.
Yep.
I love it.
Richard,
this is fantastic.
Thank you.
I am feeling this delicious set of adult beverages that you've laid before me,
right on.
I've,
I've been,
I've been sipping two of them and then we have Tecate a tutor and then this was
the [inaudible] drew dour tenure.
Delicious.
It's everybody.
Check it out.
Also visit Yo bets everywhere on the interwebs and you can find the show notes.
As always,
links to everything that we talked about@fourhourworkweek.com all spelled out.
Click on podcast or just four hour workweek.com forward slash podcast you can
also find every other episode and all the show links and shown associated with
those and as always,
thank you so much for listening.
Until next time,
bye.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my God,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important,
it will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me,
it just covers the basis.
Takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash
this episode
is brought to you by me undies.
If I'm not going commando,
I'm in the Andes.
I have been testing these underwear for three to four months now pretty much
every day and in fact throughout bunch of my other underwear this morning and on
the road in the house,
they are extremely comfortable.
They look good,
feel good.
They are made of micro modal,
two times softer than cotton and scientifically tested using the call.
Bottom method sounds very fancy of course,
and I get a lot of compliments from ladies for these.
You don't get diaper butt,
you don't get the tired elastic band.
They look great and they have underwear for both men and women.
Check out [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim and you can see everything I'd
been wearing.
They're ridiculous to the sublime.
Everything in between and colluding.
My favorite,
which is called out,
and I would be remiss if I didn't mention their lounge pants.
This is a new thing,
and I've been wearing their lounge pants when I record podcasts.
I've been wearing them out and about when I'm walking the dog meeting people for
coffee.
And they are extremely comfortable.
They're made from the same material as the underwear.
But some of them,
like the blue ones,
I have have pockets.
So you can walk about without seeming like you're off of your meds and
completely crazy.
So that is awesome.
And if you're not happy with the first pair you try on ice,
and that refers to the underwear,
they'll refund you completely.
And you can keep the pair you tried on for free.
But if you're that kind of person,
you should be ashamed because that's disgusting.
Uh,
me,
Andy's
dot com slash Tim,
check it out.
And until next time,
thank you for listening.
Okay.